İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 2 Aralık 2024 Pazartesi günü Aralık ayının ilk dersi saat 19.30.
44. ders günümüz. Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz.
Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Evet, geçen hafta en son Associative Containers grubunda kalmıştık.
Burada 4 tane konteynerımız var.
StudSet, StudMultiset, StudMap ve StudMultimap.
Biraz hatırlatma yapalım. Ondan sonra kaldığımız yere hemen geri döneceğiz.
Arkadaşlar, set nasıl bir konteyner?
Öğeleri tutuyor ama onları bir karşılaştırma kriteriyle tutuyor.
Buna komparatör diyoruz. Arka planda kullanılan template parametresi olan türü.
Setin şöyle bir konteyner olduğunu söyledik.
Hem set hem multi set.
Sesinizi alamıyorum diyor bir arkadaşım ama bir problem olduğunu sanmıyorum.
Yoksa hemen diğer arkadaşlarım da yazardı.
Setin şöyle bir konteyner olduğunu hatırlatalım.
Birinci template parametresi sette tutulacak öğenin türü.
İkinci template parametresi karşılaştırma kriteri türü ki default argüman olarak
lesson int specialization'ı alıyor.
Ve üçüncü parametre de allocator.
Diğer konteynerlerde olduğu gibi allocator'ın konteynerde tutulan öğe specialization'ı.
Yani allocator'ın int specialization'ı.
Set ile multi set arasındaki fark neydi?
Set aynı anahtardan, İngilizce kullanılan terim key, bir tane tutabiliyordu.
İkinciyi insert etmek istediğimizde insert işlemi gerçekleşmeyecek.
Oysa multi set aynı anahtardan birden fazla değer tutabiliyor idi.
Arkadaşlar associative containers grubunun konstruktörleri sequence containers grubu gibi değil.
Burada örneğin zaten mantıklı da olmazdı.
Bu değere sahip bu kadar tane öğeyle başlatmak mümkün değil.
Initializer list constructor, range constructor, default constructor, copy constructor ve move constructor var.
Burada kritik nokta ne arkadaşlar?
Biz sette tutulacak öğeleri sınıfın insert işlemi yapan fonksiyonlarından birini çağırarak ekliyoruz.
Ekleme işlemi değerle yapılıyor ve equivalence kriteri kullanılıyor.
Yani örneğin karşılaştırma kriteri studless ise bu ne demek?
Sette o değere sahip öğenin bulunup bulunmadığını sorgulamak için
A küçüktür B'nin değili ve aynı zamanda B küçüktür A'nın değili ifadesi kullanılıyor.
Ve burada komparatör olarak kullanılan türün İngilizce strict week ordering denilen dört tane kriteri karşılaması gerektiğini de söyledik.
Örneğin A küçüktür B doğruysa B küçüktür A yanlış olmalı.
A küçüktür A her zaman yanlış olmalı.
A küçüktür B doğru ve B küçüktür C doğruysa A küçüktür C doğru olmalı.
Bir de transitivity of equivalence vardı.
A B'den küçük değilse B'de C'den küçük değilse arkadaşlar ve özür dilerim A B'den küçükse B'de A'dan küçük değilse B'de A'dan küçük değilse A eşit B demek.
Aynı şekilde B C'den küçük değilse C'de B'den küçük değilse bu da B ekivalent yine C demek.
Bu durumda ne de doğru olmalı A küçüktür C arkadaşlarının değili ve A C küçüktür A'nın değili yine arkadaşlar doğru olmalı dedik.
Geçen derslerde bunları gördük.
Ondan sonra sınıfın üye fonksiyonlarını görmeye başladık.
Burada kritik fonksiyonlardan biri insert.
Dedi ki insert fonksiyonu eğer insert edilecek sette tutulan üye yani fonksiyona göndereceğimiz argüman ona key diyorduk.
Zaten sette varsa ekleme işlemi gerçekleşmeyecek yapılmayacak yoksa yapılacak.
Bunu set'in geri dönüş değerinden insert'in geri dönüş değerinden alabiliyoruz değil mi?
Insert'in geri dönüş değeri iteratör bullpair'i.
Geçen dersde örnek yapmıştık.
Eğer ekleme gerçekleşmişse isterseniz o örneğe tekrar bir geri dönelim.
Mesela set'in int virgül string açılımı myset.
String başlık dosyasında dahil edelim.
Ve dedik ki örneğin sette initializer list konstruktör ile zaten 2 ve Alihan arkadaşlar 2 ve Alihan int string açılımı demişim.
İnt açılımı 2 arkadaşlar 2, 7, 9, 13 değerleri olsun ve örneğin myset'e 7 değerini eklemeye çalışalım.
Insert 7, insert 7, geri dönüş değeri iteratör bullpair'i.
Eğer o da type deduction olmasaydı ne diyecektik?
Set'in arkadaşlar pair'in, özür dilerim pair'in set'in int açılımının iteratörü ve bull açılımı return value.
Ve buradan second'a bakacaktık.
If retin second'ı true ise ekleme işleminin yapıldığını anlayacaktık.
Bull değer.
Eğer yanlışsa arkadaşlar ekleme işleminin yapılmadığını anlayacaktık.
Ve bu durumda biz retin first'e olan iteratörü kullandığımızda ekleme yapılmışsa eklenmiş öğe'ye iteratör olacaktır.
Ekleme yapılmamışsa arkadaşlar zaten sette var olan öğe'ye iteratör olacaktır.
Burada ama iki şansımız daha var.
Bir türü açıkça yazmadan derleyicinin çıkarımına bırakmak.
Auto diyelim ki arkadaşlar P, pair'in P'si eşittir.
Read eşittir.
Myset'in insert'ü.
Şimdi artık P'nin first'u ve second'u diye erişeceğiz.
Ya da henüz detaylı görmesek de Structured Binding denilen C++17 ile eklenen önemli araçtan faydalanacaktık.
Arkadaşlar o da nasıl olacaktı?
Auto iter ne dedik?
Inserted.
Aslında aynı kodun üretildiğini söyleyebiliriz.
Ama orası biraz gelecekteki bir dersimizin konusu.
Tabi her zaman şöyle bir şansımız da var.
Insertion yapılmışsa setin size'ı artacak.
Insertion yapılmadıysa setin size'ı artmayacak.
Sette ekleme değerle arkadaşlar silme ve ekleme silme ve bir de ne dedik?
Arkadaşlar arama bunlar o log'en karmaşıklığında.
Bu arada geçen derste bu sıralı veri yapıları üstünde işlem yapan 3 tane algoritmayı da gördük.
Aslında daha da göreceğiz.
Neydi bunlar?
Lower bound, upper bound ve equal range.
Bunlar sorted range üstünde işlem yapan algoritmalardı.
Lower bound, upper bound, equal range ne demek onları açıkladık.
Ama sette zaten böyle bir sıralı olma durumu var değil mi içsel düzende.
O yüzden lower bound, upper bound ve equal range setin neleri?
Set ve map grubunun üye fonksiyonları doğruluyor.
Yani set için algoritmaları kullanmak yerine doğrudan setin üye fonksiyonları lower bound, upper bound ve equal range'i kullanabiliyoruz dedik.
Evet, şimdi insert fonksiyonu o log'en karmaşıklığında eklemeyi yapıyor ya da anahtar varsa yapamıyor.
Burada normalde kritik arkadaşlar ekleme işleminin yapılması için başka alternatifler de var.
Burası bence önemli.
Arkadaşlar alternatiflerden biri şüphesiz emplase fonksiyonu.
Yani tıpkı diğer konteynerlerde olduğu gibi emplase fonksiyonu kopyalama ya da taşıma semantinden faydalanmadan ne yapıyor?
Aldığı argümanları perfect forward ederek setin sağladığı bellek alanında bu nesneyi konstat ediyor.
Yani burada diğer konteynerlardan fazlaca bir farkı yok.
Yani örneğin elimizde hazır bulunduğu için date başlık dosyasını dahil edelim.
Ve setin date açılımını specializationında bir nesne oluşturalım.
Şimdi insert fonksiyonunu çağırırsak buraya bir date geçmemiz gerekiyor değil mi?
Örneğin date 12.5.1987.
Bu arada söylemeye gerek var mı?
Tabii ki bu setin date virgül, lesson date virgül, allocator'ın date açılımı.
Ama emplase fonksiyonunu çağırarak date'in konstruktörlerinden birine ki bu default konstruktörü de olabilir, code konstruktörü de olabilir, mom konstruktörü de olabilir.
Gönderecek argümanları geçiyorum.
Örneğin bugünün tarihi olan 2.12.2024.
Arkadaşlar, iki arama işlemleri.
Setin zaten temel varlık nedenlerinden en önemlisi logaritmik karmaşıklıkta sette var mı yok mu sorusunun cevabını alabilmemiz.
İşte bunun için hangi fonksiyonlar var bir bakalım.
Arkadaşlar, birinci fonksiyon C++'dan daha modern C++'dan önce de tabii ki var olan find fonksiyonu.
Örneğin, setin int açılımı myset.
Efendim, neutrity başlık dosyamızı da include edelim.
Biz setimizi dolduralım.
Allah'ın izniyle random field myset arkadaşlar 20 tane irand 0, efendim 100 arasında değeri değişecek.
Tam sayıları sete random field'e ekliyorum.
Şimdi seti dolaştığım zaman less'in int açılımını kullandığım için küçükten büyüğe dolaşacağım.
Yani ister range-based for loop'la dolaşayım ki daha çok bunu tercih ederim.
Auto-i myset.
IELTS-TRIM başlık dosyasını dahil edelim.
Ve arkadaşlar Cout-i.
Şimdi şu sıralama kriterini de bir kez daha göstermiş olalım.
Evet, gördüğümüz gibi küçükten büyüğe sıralı.
Eğer komparatör olarak örneğin greater'ı kullansaydım, setin int virgül, greater'ın int açılımı, karşılaştırma kriteri büyüktür operatörü olacaktı, büyüktürten küçü olacaktı.
Yine burada ne yapabilirim?
Kendi komparatörümü bir fonksiyon olarak, bir free function olarak, bir function object sınıfı olarak ya da bir lambda ifadesinden elde edilecek bir cloiler type olarak verebilirim.
Ama tabii başta da söylediğim gibi neyi karşılaması gerekiyor?
Strict vehicle ordering kriterlerini karşılaması gerekiyor.
Aksi halde tanımsız davranış olacağını unutmayalım.
Peki biz şimdi setimize geri dönelim.
Yine lesson int açılımını kullanalım.
Burada en çok işimize yarayan üye fonksiyon.
Hangi durumda undefined behavior dediniz?
Söyleyeyim Emirhan bir daha.
Komparatör olarak kullandığımız tür, eğer geçen derste anlattığım, bugünkü dersin başında da tekrar ettiğim,
İngilizce'de strict vehicle ordering denilen dört tane kriteri,
yani o strict vehicle ordering'in kapsamındaki dört tane kriterden birini bile karşılaması,
tanımsız davranış.
Mesela şöyle bir şey yazabilir miyim?
Bir örnek.
Emirhan tanımsız davranışa hemen bir örnek verelim.
Bakınız, struct, iComp, bool, operatör fonksiyon çağrı, int x, int y, const, x, küçük eşit, y.
Mesela bu bariz şekilde Emirhan, strict vehicle ordering kriterlerini karşılamıyor.
Dolayısıyla ben şimdi set'in int virgül, iComp açılımını oluştursam,
artık bundan sonra yaptığım ekleme, silme ya da arama işlemleri tanımsız davranış durumuna gelecek.
Bahsettiğim buydu.
Mesela bu hangi kriteri karşılamıyor?
A küçüktür, B yanlışsa, yani A operation B yanlış ise, doğru ise, B operation A'nın yanlış olması gerekiyor.
Ama şimdi burada iki site doğru olabilir değil mi?
Evet.
Eşit olması olabilirdi.
Ama eşit olmasa da, Kaan Can, doğru söylüyorsunuz ama eşit olmasa da zaten böyle bir şey yazma ihtiyacı olmazdı.
O zaten Kaan nedir?
Stut, Les'in, ha kendisi, bravo.
Peki, bu soruya cevap verdiysek, devam edelim.
Ve arkadaşlar, set'in yine int açılımı olsun.
Şimdi arama yapacağım.
Arkadaşlar, burada aramanın amacı ne?
Var mı, yok mu?
Yalnız bir şeye dikkat.
Bu malti set olsaydı, malti sette aranan değerden birden fazla olabilirdi değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Ama sette zaten arkadaşlar değer ya var ya yok.
Çünkü ikinci aynı anahtara sahip, aynı değere sahip ikinci anahtarı sokamıyorum sete.
Ve sağ ol bakınız, çok basit örnekle başlayalım.
Hatta şöyle biraz sette ki öğe miktarını da azaltalım.
Ve ilk arama fonksiyonumuzu çağıralım.
See out.
Arkadaşlar, aranacak değer.
Enter the key value.
Şimdi artık buradaki idiomatik yapıyı, boilerplate yapıyı öğrendik.
Ama son kez tekrar etmek istiyorum.
Bundan sonraki örnekler de açıklamayacağım.
Arkadaşlar, ne yapacağım?
Find fonksiyonunu çağıracağım değil mi?
Find, ama burada çağırdığım Find, setin üye fonksiyonu olan var.
Yani global algoritmadan bahsettiğim, bilmiyorum.
Necati, global algoritmayı çağırsam yine çalışır mı?
Çalışır ama o en karmaşıklığında olur.
Ve karşılaştırmayı, burada en çok sorulan mülakat sorularından biri.
Bakın şimdi, eğer Find algoritmasını kullanırsanız, yani algoritm başlık dosyasında iki tane önemli farklılık olur.
Bir, bir algoritmanın karmaşıklığı.
Setin kendi arama fonksiyonu, orlogen karmaşıklığında, arka planda ikili arama ağacının, arkadaşlar, ikili arama ağacında biz arama yapıyoruz.
Ve burada kriter olarak, arkadaşlar, studless ve equivalence kullanılıyor.
Yani eşit eşit operatörü kullanılmıyor.
Yani örneğin sınıfın eşit eşit operatörü olmasa, sadece küçüktür operatörü olsa, ben sınıfın Find fonksiyonunu kullanabilir miyim?
Evet.
Ama Kaan, eğer global find'ı kullanırsam, o equal to'yu kullanıyor.
Yani eşit eşit kullanıyor.
O zaman sınıfın eşit eşit operatör fonksiyonunun olması lazım.
Ve karmaşıklık, o logenden, o, n'e yükseliyor.
Finding, arkadaşlar, hemen çağrısını yapalım o zaman.
My set'in find'ı.
Normal find algoritmasında olduğu gibi, geri dönüş değeri iteratör.
Dolayısıyla my set'in find'ı, x, geri dönüş değerini bir iteratör değişkende saklıyorum.
Ve ondan sonra da my set'in end'ine eşit dinli sunuyorum.
If, iter, eşit eşit, my set'in end'i, see out, bulunamadı.
As, see out, tabi bu biri Türkçe, biri İngilizce olmasın.
Not found, found ve ona erişiyorum.
Tabi erişip de burada yapabileceğim bir şey yok.
Çünkü zaten eriştiğim öğenin değeri, zaten aramada kullandığım değer.
Ben sadece size göstermek için yazdım.
Enter the key value, 31 arkadaşlar.
Pound, enter the key value, 16, not found.
Arkadaşlar şimdi bir iki nokta artık bunları bundan sonraki derslerde tekrar etmeyeceğim.
Bir, bu tür durumlarda eğer if deyiminden sonra fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini kullanmayacaksanız
ve derleyiciniz de C++17 standardını destekliyorsa ki artık arkadaşlarımın çalıştığı kurumların hemen hepsinde
minimal C++17 destekleniyor, kullanıyorlar yani destekleniyor.
Yeterli değil, şirketin de kullanma konusunda kararlı olması gerekiyor.
Dolayısıyla neyi kullanabilirim?
If with initializer kullanabilirim değil mi?
Yani şöyle de yazabilirdim.
If auto iter eşittir, pardon şu find kısmında, silim tekrar yazayım.
İlk auto iter eşittir, my set'in find'ı, anahtar ve iter eşit olmadığı, iter eşit değilse my set'in end'i.
Bu durumda zaten skokunu da doğrudan ilgili ismin daraltmış oluyorum.
Herhalde burada anlaşılmadık bir şey yok.
Arkadaşlar ben aksiyonda bir zorlama olmadığı sürece ve yine if deyimi dışında söz konusu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini kullanma ihtiyacı olmadığı sürece
mutlaka if with initializer'ı kullanıyorum.
Kod kalitesi açısından gerçekten bence son derece önemli skoplayı kaçıyor.
Peki arkadaşlar ama set'in yine modern C++'dan önce de var olan bir de count isimli bir fonksiyonu var.
Set'in count fonksiyonu arkadaşlar anahtardan kaç tane olduğu değerini döndürüyor.
Eee necati set ise zaten ya sıfır ya bir.
Evet set ise ya sıfır ya bir ama multi set ise birden fazla olabilir.
Bu arada bir şey daha göstermek istiyorum.
Bakınız bunu multi set yapalım arkadaşlar.
Ve buraya elli tane öğe koyalım.
Ve öğeler sıfır on aralığında olsun arkadaşlar.
Ve kodu biraz değiştireyim.
Aramada bir değerini arayalım.
Auto biter eşittir.
My set'in find'ı bir.
Neyi göstereceğimi tahmin edebiliyor musunuz?
Peki burada birden fazla bir var.
İlkini bulma garantisi var mı?
Var ya da yok diye tahminde bulunabilirsiniz.
Soruyu anladınız mı?
Biriler artı çık.
Yani kendi karşılaştırma kriterine göre.
Onlardan ilkini bulma garantisi var mı?
Yani eğer şöyle bir kod yazsam.
If iter eşit değildir.
My set'in end'i.
See out.
Count.
Distance eşittir.
Distance.
Maalesef tabii bi-directional iteratör olduğu için
Muhammed çıkartma operatörünü kullanamıyorum değil mi?
My set'in begin'i iter.
Ve distance değerini yazdıralım.
Frontime'e bakıyoruz.
Evet arkadaşlar.
Point.
Distance eşittir 5.
Bakın 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Bu bir tesadüf mü?
Değil.
Bu garanti var.
Mesela distance eşittir 7.
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Takip edebildik mi?
O zaman birinci arama fonksiyonumuz find.
Multi set'te o eş değere sahip, ekivalent değere sahip böyelerden 2'nin konumunu bulma garantisi var.
Biz tekrar set'e geri dönelim arkadaşlar.
Multi set değil, set olsun.
Ve yine buraya 0, 100 aralığında 10 tane değerimiz olsun.
Bu kez ikinci arama fonksiyonu.
Aslında bu da bir arama fonksiyonu.
İsminin count olduğuna bakmayın.
Count'a bakalım.
Arkadaşlar, count size iteratör döndürmüyor.
O eden kaç tane var?
O bilgiyi döndürüyor.
Ama sonuçta bu yine var mı yok mu sorusunun cevabı değil mi?
Yani örneğin arkadaşlar, int n eşittir my set'in count'u.
Orada n'in değeri diyelim ki 7'yi arayayım.
n'in değeri ya 0 ya 1.
Dolayısıyla multi set ise belki bu n değeri işinize yarayabilir.
Ama set ise örneğin bunu sorgulama amaçlı kullanabilirsiniz.
Diğerine göre maliyeti halk tabiriyle, gençlik tabiriyle bir tık daha az.
Çünkü sadece bir tam sayı karşılaştırması yapıyorsunuz.
See out, in set ve else, not in set.
Örneğin önce olan bir değerle gösterelim.
Arkadaşlar, not in set 7 yokmuş.
Evet, olan değerle göstermek için biraz sayı da arttıralım.
80 tane ö olsun.
Ve bakalım bu sefer.
Her defa aslında rastgele geliyor bu arada.
Evet, not in set.
Hatta şurada bir de new line verelim.
Ve arka arkaya birkaç kere çalıştırayım.
Evet, 100 tane yerden in set.
Bakın şu durumda var.
Görüyorsunuz 7'nin var olduğunu görüyorsunuz.
Bu multi set olsaydı
da bu kod yine doğru olacaktı.
Fakat count'ın geri dönüş değeri sette o değerden kaç tane var sorusunun cevabı olacaktı.
Örneğin 0, 30 aralığında olsun.
Bu kez doğrudan count'un geri dönüş değerini yazdıralım.
See out
my set'in
count'u
arkadaşlar
12.
12'den kaç tane var?
Ama tabii
0'sa sette o değerden, multi sette o değerden hiç yok demek.
Bu arada
multi set'in
insert fonksiyonunu
geçen derste söyledim.
Tabii ki set'in
insert fonksiyonunda olduğu gibi
iteratör olduğundan farklı
şekilde
iteratör
bullpair'i döndürmek yerine
sadece
iteratör döndürüyor.
Değil mi?
Peki
count'u da gördük.
Arkadaşlar daha sonra
C++20 ile
contents fonksiyonunda eklendi.
Gerçekten de gerekiyordu.
Yani artık doğrudan şöyle yazabilirsiniz.
Eğer
sorunuz var mı yok mu ise
sadece
amacınız bu sorunun cevabını almaksa
doğrudan
my set
arkadaşlar
contents
örneğin
boolean döndürüyor
doğrudan
C art
evet var
else
hayır yok
yok
hemen derleyelim
hayır yok ama
olabilirdi
evet var
bir go değişmiyor
yani algoritmanın karmaşıklığı
computational
kompleksliği
değişmiyor
yine bunların hepsi
o
login karmaşıklığında
anlaşıldı mı?
evet
şimdi arkadaşlar
bu
arama tarafı
bir kez daha tekrar edelim mi
find fonksiyonu
iteratör döndürüyor
efendim
found fonksiyonu
kaç tane
ue var
onu döndürüyor
ve
bir de ne var
contents fonksiyonu var
ama C++ 20
o da
doğrudan
boolean
değer döndürüyor
yani varsa
true değer döndürecek
yoksa
false değer döndürecek
arkadaşlar bir şey
dikkat edelim
bu yine
üretimde yapılan
tipik hatalardan biri
şimdi bakın
setteki
anahtar
const olarak
ele alınıyor
yani örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazamazsınız
mesela burada
doğrudan
şöyle bir kod
yazmaya çalışsam
auto iter
arkadaşlar
eşittir
my set'in
begin'i
arkadaşlar
bu
iteratör konumundaki
öe
const
dolayısıyla siz
yıldız iter'i
set edemezsiniz
örneğin bunu
atama operatörüne
operanda yapsanız
sentaks hatası olur
çünkü
const pinesinde
yine örneğin
bu set'in
string açılımı
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
birkaç tane de
değer koyalım
Ali'ye
Necati
Hakan
Nur'dan
yine örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazsaydım
auto iter eşittir
maalesef
herhangi bir
begin'i
iteratör konumu
ve örneğin
iter
og
bir
non
const
dünya
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yapsam
assign
arkadaşlar
doğrudan yine
sentaks hatası
olacak
gönderdiğim argümanın
ne olduğundan
bağımsız olarak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
set'teki
konumlardaki
öeler
arkadaşlar
nedir
const
nelerdir
burada şöyle bir
hata yapılıyor
arkadaşlar siz
sentaks engelini
her zaman
aşabilirsiniz
yani örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazsam
izleyin
tabi
yazmayacağız
hiçbir zaman
efendim
desek ki
yıldız iter
o iteratör
konumundaki
nesne
değil mi
evet
necu
efendim
const
kest
string
ref
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ee
şimdi artık bu
lvalue
expression oldu
constu
gitti
non
const
lvalue
expression oldu
ve
bunu
adama
yapsam
bakın
sentaks
engelini
açtım
ama bu
tabi ki
tanımsız
davranış
veri yapısını
ingilizcesiyle
corrupt etmiş oldum
çünkü bu
arkadaşlar
osmanın yerinin
neresi olacağı
belli
istediğim yerdeki
bir öğenin
değerini
değiştiremem
eğer
anahtarı
değiştirmek
istiyorsam
onu yapmanın
başka yolları var
anladınız değil mi
sette tutulan
öğeyi
değiştiremezsiniz
nasıl değiştireceğimizi
ayrıca göstereceğim
ama gidip
o konumdaki
nesneye
sentaks engelini
aşıp
atama yaparsanız
onu
mutate
etme
girişiminde
bulunursanız
sentaks
engelini
açsak
dahi
yani
derli
için
kontrolünden
kaçınsak
dahi
bu sefer
tanımsız
davranış
olacak
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi devam
edelim
find
count
ve
contains
fonksiyonlarını
gördük
sette
arkadaşlar
arama
yapan
sete
ekleme
yapan
and place
ve insert
fonksiyonlarını
gördük
şimdi gelelim
silme
işlemlerine
arkadaşlar bu arada
yine
biraz zamanı
oynayayım
ben
sette köyeleri
yazdırırken de
nasıl olsa artık
iteratör semantiliyle
dolaşmayı
biliyoruz
yine ne yapayım
benim
jprint
fonksiyonumu
kullanayım
hata hata
seti
rastgele
öğelerle
doldurmak için
yine
random
fil isimli
benim
template fonksiyonumu
kullanayım
my set
efendim
ve
random
name
10 tane
string tutuyor
şu anda
setimiz
batıl
bekir
fikret
gül
malik
niyazi
papatya
rupen
taci
ve
tansu
şimdi
gelelim
silme işlemlerine
diğer konteynerlarda
olduğu gibi
sette de
daha doğrusu
asosyatif
konteynerlarda da
a
iteratör
konumu ile silen
arkadaşlar
b
iteratör
range'ini silen
erase
fonksiyonları
var
yani
örneğin
my set'in
erase'i
arkadaşlar
buraya
anahtar
değerini
değil de
şu overload'u
kullanacağım
iteratör
evet mesela
my set'in
begin'i
set'teki ilk öğeyi
set'ten
silmiş oldum
hemen bunu bir
gösterelim
görüyorsunuz
altı
silindi
arkadaşlar
mesela
son öğeyi
silmek
istesem
my set'in
yine
erase'i
my set'in
end'ini
breve
argüman olarak
göndereyim
ve
son öğeyi
son öğeyinin
konumunu
verdiğime göre
son öğeyi
silmiş oldum
bu sefer de
son öğeyi
bu
sequence
konteyner'larda da
olan
arkadaşlar
iteratör
tabii
forward list
hariç
onu konuşmuştuk
iteratör konumuyla
silen
fonksiyon
ya da
şuna
bakınız
range
parametreli
yani iki
iteratör
parametreli
silme
fonksiyonumuzda
var
örneğin
yine daha önce
benzer
kodları
yazmıştık
my set'in
erase'i
ilk
dört öğeyi
silmek isteyeyim
my set'in
begin'i
tabii burada
toplama operatörü
iteratörümüz
toplama operatörünün
operanda olamaz
çünkü
bi-directional
iteratör
yine
next'i
kullanacağım
eğer elimde
daha önceden
konu tutulmuş
bir iteratör
konumu yoksa
next
my set
begin
bir gül
arkadaşlar
üç
böylece
dört mü
demiştik
ilk dört öğeyi
silmiş
olacağım
yani burada
sequence
konteynerlara göre
bir farklılık
yok
arkadaşlar
izleyin
gördüğümüz gibi
ilk dört öğeyi
olan
Adnan
Atakan
Azmi
ve Çetin
silindiler
artık setimizdeki
ilk öğe
dost
isimli
dostumuz
arkadaşımız
evet
ama
bakınız
bir de
değerle silme
yapan fonksiyonumuz
var
mesela
string
name
see out
enter
the name
to
erase
see in
name
my set
arkadaşlar
erase
bakın
doğrudan
görüyorsunuz
anahtarı
istiyor
name
geri dönüş
değeri
silinen
öğe sayısı
tabi
eğer setse
geri dönüş
değeri
sıfır
ya da bir
olacak
ama
mal
setse
birden fazla
olabilir
değil mi
o zaman
see out
arkadaşlar
n
öğe
silindi
ve
yine
c
print
fonksiyonuyla
setimizdeki
öğeleri
yazdıralım
aynısını bir de
multi setle deniriz
enter the name
to erase
garo
bir eleman
silindi
ve
faziletle
niyazi
arasındaki
garo
ismi
silindi
bu kez
multi set
yapalım
300 tane
öğe koyalım
hatta 500 tane
ama yazdırmayalım
birden fazla
silinebileceğini
göstermek için
garo
bir eleman
silindi
garo
yokmuş
aynı
iki
bakanın içinde
iki tane
varmış
garo
dan
ikisi de
silindi
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok dikkatli
izlemenizi istiyorum
biraz doğru bir kısım
başlıyor
setteki
anahtarı
değiştirmek
bu mülakatlarda
programcılara
sorulan
çok tipik
soru olduğu için
çok iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
burayı
çünkü
bir modern
c++
öncesi
daha doğrusu
c++
modern c++
öncesi
ve eski c++
nasıl yapılıyordu
ikisini de göstereceğim
o yüzden
dikkatli izlemeniz
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bakınız
yine
bizimki
set olsun
setin string
açılımı
ve
20 tane
ö olsun
ya da
10 tane
ö olsun
jprint
fonksiyonuyla
setimizdeki
isimleri
yazdıralım
ve şimdi
biz bir
anahtarı
değiştirmek
isteyelim
fakat şöyle
diyelim
string
old name
arkadaşlar
ve
new name
yani
old name
eski anahtarı
olacak
new name
yeni anahtarı
olacak
isterseniz doğrudan
key
sözcüğünü
kullanın
old key
new key
yetişik olsun
underscore
kullanmayın
siyah alt
türkçeyi yazayım
misal
eski
ve
yeni
anahtarlar
seen
old key
new key
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ve şimdi
old key'in yerine
emiran
new key'i koyacağız
tabii ki şunu yapacağız
değil mi
eğer old key varsa
onu sileceğiz
new key'i de
insert edeceğiz
o zaman
arkadaşlar
if
eze'in
auto
iter
eşittir
my set'in
find'ı
alt set değil bu arada
ve
o key
iter
eşit değilse
my set'in end'i
demek ki varmış
my set'in
erase'i
iter
iter konumuyla
sevebiliyordum ya
my set'in
insert'ü
arkadaşlar
new key
evet
ve
see out
anahtar
değişti
ve
tekrar
set'teki
üyeleri
yazdıralım
see out
see print
container print
my set
else durumunda da
bir out
bulunamadı
derliyorum
evet eski ve yeni anahtar
önce başarılı bir örneğe
girelim
örneğin
ceylan
ne olsun
arkadaşlar
honguç
anahtar değişti
bakın
asım
ceyda
andesudan önce
ceylan var
idi
ve römeysa
zerrin arasında
honguç
yok idi
değişti
şimdi burada
problematik bir nokta vardı
eskisi
plus plus
bakalım
fark edebilecek misiniz
arkadaşlar
silme işlemi
buradaki
üveyi
destro ediyor
değil mi
cevap
evet
buraya dikkat
öyü
destroy ediyor
ama biz
yeni anahtarı
ekliyoruz
o tekrar
konstrakt ediyor
yeni
anahtarlı
nesneyi
bu string
olmak zorunda
değil
bir başka
construction
destruction
maliyeti
çok daha yüksek
bir sınıfta
olabilirdi
oysa şöyle bir
gerçek var
burayı izleyin
arkadaşlar
arka plandaki
implementasyon
bu ikili
arama ağacı
olduğuna göre
yine
notları
kullanıyor
değil mi
yani aslında
bizim setimiz
notlardan
oluşuyor
tabi ikili
arama ağacı
veri yapısını
belirli bir ölçüde
bildiğinizi
varsayıyorum
konu
ikili
arama ağacı
veri yapısıyla
ilgili değil
doğrudan
mesela
bu benim
değiştirmek
istediğim
eski anahtar
Leyla
bunun yerine
arkadaşlar
ben yeni
anahtarı
koymak istiyorum
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ben bunu
setten
sildiğim
zaman
setteki
ö
destroy oluyor
tabi ki
bu
notta
arka planda
dynamic olarak
allocate edildiği
için
o da
free edilmiş
oluyor
buraya kadar
anladık mı
peki şu
yapılamaz mı
ya
madem
set kendi
düğümlerine
hakim
modlarına
bu düğümü
ben
setten
çıkartayım
ama
nesnevi
destroy etmeyeyim
düğümü
çıkartayım
buraya kadar
takip edebildiniz mi
düğümdeki
öğeyi
değiştireyim
mesela
düğümün içinde
bir
tutulan
stringin değeri
Leyla iken
mesela
ne olsun
Selami olsun
şu anda
herhangi bir şekilde
stringi
destroy ettim mi
Muhammed
hayır
ondan sonra
bunu
hatta
taşıma
semantiğinden de
faydalanarak
tekrar
insert edilmesi
gereken yere
insert edeyim
eğer böyle
bir şey
yapılırsa
gereksiz
olarak
arkadaşlar
destruction
deallocation
construction
ve tekrar
allocation
ve construction
bunlardan
kaçınmış
oluruz
değil mi
anladınız mı
buraya kadar
gerçekten
modern
C++
öncesinde
bu
böyle bir
imkan
yok
idi
ama
şimdi
modern
C++
da
buna
çok güzel
bir önlem
aldılar
bakın bakın
ne yapılıyor
çok dikkatli
izleyin
sınıfın
extract
isimli
bir fonksiyonu
var
extract
fonksiyonunun
hatta
iki tane
overload'u
var
overload'lardan
biri
key oluyor
arkadaşlar
diğer overload
iteratör oluyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
iteratör alan
o iteratör
konumundaki
nodu
tabiri caizse
türkçe terim
kullanacağım
kopartıyor
çıkartıyor
oradan
ama
nodu
deallocate
etmiyor
nodun içindeki
nesneyi
destroy etmiyor
ve
extract fonksiyonu
bize
bir
geri dönüş
değeri veriyor
hadi bakın
şimdi
mesela
şu if'in
doğru kısmını
değiştirelim
ve
şöyle
extract fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
auto
red
arkadaşlar
eşittir
my set'in
extract'i
efendim
old
key
old key diyorum
özür dilerim
iter
old key dediğim
ama
zaten gerek yok
aradım
arkadaşlar
bakın
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerine
bakarsanız
aslında
bu
geri planda
node handle
denilen
bir türden
ama
o türünde
bir
interfeysi var
izleyin
ben şimdi
red nokta
dediğimde
aslında bu
extract fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri olan
arkadaşlar
node handle
diyelim o türe
node handle'ın
üye fonksiyonları
empty fonksiyonu
node'la data
var mı
yok mu
onu sınıyor
value fonksiyonu
bizi
data'ya eriştiriyor
yine
operator
bool fonksiyonu
data var mı
yok mu
sorusuna cevap veriyor
arkadaşlar
şu anda
data var mı
yok mu
diye bir kontrol
yapmama gerek var mı
yok
zaten buldum
ama ben
extract fonksiyonunu
şöyle çağırsaydım
örneğin
deseydim ki
auto handle
eşittir
maalesef
extracti
bu arada
lütfen
anlamadığınız
noktaları
tekrar etmemi isteyin
çünkü özellikle
bu benim
öğrencilerimle
çok konuşuyorum
böyle yurt dışı
firmaların
mülakatlarına
falan
mülakatlarda
soruyorlar
maalesef
extracti
izleyin
arkadaşlar
key
şimdi
bu anahtar
key derken
tabi burada
all key
bu anahtar
olmaya da
bilir
ola da bilir
eğer bu anahtar var ise
handle'ımız
dolu olacak
şöyle kontrol edebilirsiniz
operatör
boğul fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
ya da
doğrudan
az önce gösterdiğim
empty fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirsiniz
boş mu
dolu mu
anlaşıldı mı
peki
o zaman oraya kadar
geldik
yani
extract fonksiyonuna
artık
hangisini
terşi ediyorsam
anahtarı
verebilirim
ya da daha önceden
işte bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
arama yapmışımdır
zaten
olduğunu
bildiğime göre
artık
geri dönüş
değeri olan
handle'ın
yani o
nodu temsil ediyor
dataya sahip
olduğunu
biliyorum
peki şimdi
ne yapacağım
şimdi
nesneyi
destroy etmeden
arkadaşlar
yine handle
diyelim
isterseniz
nesneyi
destroy etmeden
içindeki
dataya
referans
emantiyle
erişeceğim
şöyle ki
handle'ın
values'u
ve
bunun değerini
değiştireceğim
örneğin
new key'i
yaptım
ve yalnız
burada dikkat
sınıfın
ne isteyen
bir de
insert fonksiyonu
var
işte bu
handle isteyen
bir
insert
over load'u var
ama
r value
istiyor bizden
dolayısıyla
şöyle yazacağım
arkadaşlar
my set'in
insert'ü
stud move
handle
anlaşıldı mı?
yani
eğer modern
c++
kullanıyorsanız
kesinlikle
anahtar
değişikliğini
extract fonksiyonu
ile yapın
yani
extract ile
adı üstünde
extract edin
node'dan çıkartın
bu arada bir şey daha
göstermek istiyorum
ya da size sorayım
bilin ki
burada
arkadaşlar
if'in doğru
kısmına girdi
tahmin etmeye çalışın
şu anda
buraya girmeden
size
10 idi
size eşittir
my set'in
size'ı
peki
node'u
extract ettiğimde
size
azaldı mı?
a evet
azaldı
b henüz
azalmadı
cevap
azaldı
çünkü
extract
onu
çıkartıyor
düğümü
anladınız
değil mi?
yani
arkadaşlar
izleyin
size
eski bir yeni
anahtarlar
Kenan
Turgut
bakın
size 9 oldu
anlaşıldı
değil mi?
demin onu
anlatmaya çalıştım
belki orayı
kaçırmış
olabilirsiniz
işte bakın
bu anahtarı
düğümü
koparttı
yani
buradaki
pointer'ları
node içindeki
ayarladı
şu anda artık
size azaldı
ama
nesne
destroy olmadı
yani
bunun içindeki
string nesnesi
destroy olmadı
şimdi bunun
stringini
değiştirdim
ve
insert fonksiyonu
taşıma
semantiliğinden
faydalandı
tekrar
koyulması
gereken yere
koydum
anlaşıldı mı?
Muhammed
Yusuf
Oğuzhan
Esin
burası
anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
node'lar içinde
overflow
olması
mümkün mü?
Overflow'dan
neyi kastediyorsunuz?
Hayır
çünkü
node'da
arkadaşlar
bir data
tutuyorsunuz
datanın
türü belli
yani ona
başka bir
değer atama
imkanınız yok
zaten
herhangi bir şekilde
bir taşmayla
ilgili
problem
söz konusu
değil
peki
az önce
string yazdık
nerede
string yazdık?
setin
string açılımı
bir öncekinde
setin
int açılımı
idi
zaten
setin
int açılımına
herhangi bir şekilde
bir string koyamam
int koyabilirim
değil mi?
Bir önceki örnekte
o setin
int açılımı
idi
şimdi
ekstrak fonksiyonunu
buranın geri dönüş
değeri olan
node handle
türünü
burada
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanan
node'u
insert eden
insert fonksiyonunu
anladık mı
diye soralım
anlamadığımız
yer varsa
tekrar
kritik
yer varsa
anlamadığımız
orayı açıklayayım
peki devam ediyoruz
o zaman
anahtarı değiştirmenin
bir eski yolu var
yani
anahtarı sil
ve yeni
anahtarı ekle
aslında arkadaşlar
tabii
int
vesaire gibi
şeyler için
allocation
de allocation
maliyet de var
yani illa
sınıf türünden
olması gerekmiyor
yani bence
her zaman
artık yeni
yöntemi
kullanın
ekstrak fonksiyonu
eskiden
yok idi
arkadaşlar
şimdi
soruyu
yine dikkatli
izlemenizi
istiyorum
önemli bir
soru
setteki
öğelerin
konumları
var
değil mi
örneğin
ben
myset'in
begin
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
setteki
ilk öğeye
iteratör
oluyorum
peki
bu konuma
şu değeri
ekle
diyebilir miyim
Emirhan
Muhammed
Oğuzhan
bu konuma
şu değeri
ekle
diyebilir miyim
diyemem
değil mi
çünkü
yok
elvenliğe
ilgili değil
ayağın
yanlış anlaşılma
olmasın
o konuma
istediğim
konuma
değeri
ekleyemem ki
anladınız
değil mi
sıralı bir
düzende
bravo
Muhammed
kan
anlaşıldı
değil mi
ama
bakın
şimdi
sizi
şaşırtacak
bir
fonksiyon
çağrısı
myset'in
pine
diyelim ki
myset'in
insert'ü
set'i
kullananların
yanlış anladığı
tipik yerlerden biri
myset'in
insert'ü
pine
değil
myset'in
insert'ü
begin'i
ve örneğin
arkadaşlar
abidin
değerliyorum
sentax hatası yok
şimdi bunu gören
hemen şunu soruyor
hani
belirli bir
konuma
istediğim
öğeyi
ekleyemezdim
arkadaşlar
buradaki
insert
fonksiyonu
ne
yapmıyor
buraya dikkat
ne
yapmıyor
abidin'i
bu konuma
eklemiyor
bu insert
overloaduna
ingilizce'de
hint insert
diyorlar
hint ne demek
türçe en yakın
karşılığı
ipucu
değil mi
yani siz
diyorsunuz ki
ben
bu konumu
senin
başlangıç
noktası
olarak
almanı
istiyorum
eğer bu
konuma
eklenebiliyorsa
yani gerçekten
bu konum
eklenecek
konumsa
buraya ekle
ama değilse
buradan hareketle
eklenecek
konumu
bulacak
neden böyle
bir fonksiyon
var
bu arada
bu insert
ne yaptığını
herkes anladı mı
hint insert
ne yaptığını
herkes anladı mı
konumu
veriyorum
ama
konumu
vermemin
amacı
o konuma
ekle
değil
ben
bu konuma
eklenebileceğini
ya da buna
yakın bir konuma
eklenebileceğini
düşünüyorum
yani
arama
maliyetini
azaltmak
için
zaten
eklenecek
yeri
biliyorsanız
o zaman
eklenecek
konumu
zaten
biliyorsanız
neden
boş yere
arama
yapasınız ki
o konumu
veriyorsunuz
böylece
aramada
bir avantaj
sağlanıyor
en az bir
arkadaşıma
anladım
diyebilir mi
evet
buna
hint
insert
diyorum ben
ve önemli
bir fonksiyon
teşekkür ederim
arkadaşlar
ama hint
insert
bir güzel
yanı
daha var
şimdi
soru
arkadaşlar
bazı
algoritmalar
iteratör adaptörü
kullanarak
konteynera
ekleme işlemi
yapıyor
değil mi
mesela
elimde bir
vektör olsa
vektörün
string
açılımı
efendim
myvec
ve
vektör
başlık dosyası
da
sahil edilmiş
olsun
bu vektörde
random fill
myvec
on
random
name
diyelim ki
on tane
string
olsa
ve ben
örneğin
kopya
algoritmasıyla
bu vektördeki
üyeleri
bir sete
aktarmak
isteyeyim
sete
kopyalamak
isteyeyim
setin
string
açılımı
myvec
set
çok dikkatli
izleyin
önce bunu
bitireyim
olsan cevap
vereceğim
setin
string açılımı
myset
arkadaşlar
şimdi
algoritm başlık
dosyasını
include edelim
şöyle yazamam
yazamam
değil mi
myset'in
a copy
myvec
begin
kopya artık
herkes biliyor
myvec
begin
end
arkadaşlar
myset
begin
şimdi burada
arkadaşlar
iki tane
problem var
problemlerden biri
zaten set
boş
yani boş
olan sete
yazamam
ikincisi
bunun
eklenecek
yeri
belli
doğrudan
bu konuma
atama yapamam
zaten
const olarak
ele alınıyor
ama şimdi
hatırlıyor musunuz
bizim üç tane
iteratör adaptörümüz
vardı
backinsert
iteratör
kopyalamayı
atamayı
konteynerın
pushback fonksiyonuna
yapılan çareye
dönüştürüyordu
bunun ismi
neydi
backinsert
iteratör
veren fonksiyonun
ismi neydi
backinsertör
atamayı
yani
kopyalamada
kopya algoritmasında
örneğin
yapılan
atamayı
döngüsel yapı
içinde
sınıfın
pushback fonksiyonuna
değil de
pushfront fonksiyonuna
dönüştüren
oradaki
sınıfta
frontinsert
iteratör
ve frontinsert
iteratörü
veren fonksiyon da
frontinsertör idi
ama
belki o dersi
hatırlayan
birkaç arkadaşım
varsa
dedim ki
bir üçüncü
daha var
o da
insert iteratör
veren de
arkadaşlar
inserter fonksiyonu
yani
backinsertör
frontinsertör
inserter
şimdi
bu işe ne
yarıyor
ben burada
inserter fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
arkadaşlar
inserter fonksiyonunu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
inserter fonksiyonuna
ne geçeceğim
konteyner
öğesini
ve
fonumu
yani örneğin
şöyle
myset
virgül
begin
böylece
artık bu kod
legal hale
gelmiş olacak
yani
hiçbir ne bir
tanımsız davranış var
ne de legalite
açısından
bir problem var
anlaşıldı
değil mi
böyle
ama bakın
aslında
buradaki
inserterde
atamayı
neye dönüştürüyor
arkadaşlar
konteynerın
insert
fonksiyonuna
yapılan
çağırıya
dönüştürüyor
o yüzden
burada bir
sentaks hatası
olmuyor
evet orayı
hint olarak
kullanıyor
belki oranın
bizim ekleme
konumuzda
çok yakın
bir konum
olmayabilir
ama en azından
bunu
legal kılıyor
jprint
bakın
hem
vektörü
yazdırayım
jprint
myback
hem de
jprint
myset
anlaşıldı mı
hint insert'ün
ne yaptığı
evet
arkadaşımın
sorusuna
gelecek olursam
myset'in
insert'ü
arkadaşlar
myset
begin
cemile
otoyiter
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
iteratör döndürüyor
yine
sequence
konteynerlarda
olduğu gibi
sınıfın
insert
fonksiyonları
insert edilmiş
öğe'ye
arkadaşlar
iteratör döndürüyor
eğer birden fazla
öğe
insert edilmiş
olsaydı
insert edilen
ilk öğe
iteratör döndürecekti
oğuzhan
bir şeyi yanlış anladınız
hint insert
etmiyor
demedik
tabi ki
hint insert
etmiyor
demedim
bu konuma
insert etmiyor
dedim
oğuzhan
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani konum
veriyorum ama
bu konuma
insert etmiyor
insert edilmesi
gereken yer
neresiyse
oraya
insert ediyor
Abdur Kadir
anlaşıldı mı
orada bir yanlış
anlamı olmuş
benim ağzımdan
yanlış bir sözle
çıkmış olabilir
ama sanmıyorum
ben şöyle dedim
neden bir
iteratör konumu
veriyoruz
bunu
hint olarak
veriyoruz
maliyeti azaltmak
için
ama sonuçta
insert'in yapıyor mu
kesinlikle yapıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
tabi yapıyor
derken
arkadaşlar yine
setse
varsa
yapmayacak
mal setse
yapacak
evet sette
bir haydi
ilerledik
ama şimdi
biraz zor
kısmı da
yavaş yavaş
başlıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
sette
bir önemli
problem daha
vardı
bu problemi
C++
14 standardıyla
çözdüler
yani
11 standardında
bu problem
açık bir şekilde
vardı
şimdi
sette ben
arama yapacağım
arama fonksiyonu
ne istiyor
benden
cevap
aranacak
değeri istiyor
peki aranacak
değer nedir
aranacak
değer
sette
tutulacak
tutulmakta
olan
öğe
türünden
bir değer
değil mi
yani bu
ne demek
bakınız
diyelim ki
benim şöyle
bir
sınıfım olsa
struct
net
burası
bir hayli
karmaşık
o yüzden
biraz
odaklanmaya
çalışmanız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
benim şöyle
bir
efendim
neyim
olsun
sınıfım
sınıfında
ben şimdilik
public
private
erişim
kontrolü
vesaire
uygulamıyorum
çünkü konunun
doğrudan
erişim
kontrolüyle
hiçbir
alakası
yok
efendim
burada
int
türünden
örneğin
bir
veri elemanı
olsun
eval
arkadaşlar
efendim
bir de
bir vektör
olsun
vektörün
studvektörün
studstring
açılımı
vektörün
studstring
açılımı
vec
takip etmeye
çalışın
biraz
karmaşık
gerçekten
arkadaşlar
ben
sette
neç
türünden
öğeler
tutmak
isteyeyim
yani
setin
neç
açılımı
my set
ve aslında
necin de
gerçekten
küçüktür
operatör
fonksiyonu
olsun
operatör
küçük
bul
arkadaşlar
const
neç
red
const
dolayısıyla
artık
setin
neç
virgül
lessin
neç
açılımı
yazmamda
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir engel
yok ki
zaten
default
template
argümanını
kullandım
şimdi ben
diyelim ki
bu seti
populate
ettim
yani
doldurdum
o kodları
yazmayacağım
yani
diyelim ki
set
sette
belirli sayıda
eleman var
ve şimdi
ben bir
arama işlemi
yapacağım
ama
arkadaşlar
arama fonksiyonunda
arama fonksiyonuna
benim argüman
olarak ne
göndermem
gerekiyor
bir
neç
nesnesi
göndermem
gerekiyor
ee
şimdi
aranacak
değer
şöyle
değil mi
mesela
neç
efendim
ki
tabi
diğer detaylarla
ilgilenmiyoruz
şimdi my seti
örneğin
find fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
find fonksiyonuna
key'i
argüman olarak
vereceğim
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
evet
ama şimdi
bakın
eğer
ben
aramayı
intürden
böyle bir
ival
yani
yapının
sınıfın sadece
ival elemanını
kullanarak
yapmak istiyorsam
yani
benim
arama kriterim
arkadaşlar
neyse
diyelim
bu
neç
nesnesinin
int elemanıysa
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu durumda
aslında
benim
şöyle bir
karşılaştırma fonksiyonuna
ihtiyacım var
neç nesnesiyle
inti
karşılaştıracak
öyle değil mi
ama
iki yönde de
karşılaştırmanın
yapılabilmesi
gerekiyor
o zaman
şöyle fonksiyon
vereceğim
bul
operatör küçük
const
neç
rev
int
bul
operatör küçük
int
const
neç
rev
fark edebildik mi
buraya kadar
evet
ama şimdi
örneğin ben
şöyle bir kod
yazabilir miyim
arkadaşlar
diyeceğim ki
set'in
neç
virgül
ya da set'in
neç
açılımı
neç'in
key'ini
sildim
my set
find
olmaz
olmaz ki
bu fonksiyonu
çağırmayacak ki
bu durumda
sentaks hatası
olacak
ama ben neçle
arama yaparsam da
düşünsenize
içinde
devasa bir
vektör var
ben
neç'in
küçüktür
operatör fonksiyonunu
yazsam
dahi
ama bu
arama için
benim bir neç nesnesi
oluşturmam
gerekiyor
değil mi
oysa benim bir neç nesnesine
ihtiyacım yok ki
sadece bir intlere
ihtiyacım var
problemin nerede
olduğunu anladık mı
problem
bunu doğrudan
yapacak
bir
interfeysin
c++11
standardıyla
olmayışıydı
biraz zor oldu
değil mi
peki
tekrar edelim
set'in
arama fonksiyonu
bizden
argüman olarak
sette tutulacak
öğeyi istiyor
bu durumda
iki tane
olasılık var
bir
arkadaşlar
ben
küçüktür
operatörünü
öyle bir şekilde
yazacağım ki
aslında
set'teki
ilişki
tamamen
intelemana
göre olacak
ama istediğim de
o değil
istediğim
setin oluşumunda
ben gerçekten
neç'lerin
küçüklüğünü
büyüklüğünü
kullanmak istiyorum
ama
arama işleminde
neç'in
sadece
intelemanını
kullanmak istiyorum
böyle bir
arama
yapamıyorum
böyle bir
arama
yapmamın
arkadaşlar
findifle de
ama
findifle
zaten yaparsak
findifle yaparsak
zaten
arkadaşlar
eşittir
kullanmış olur
ve
linear
kompleksli olur
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bununla ilgili
buldukları
çözüm
aslında
terim olarak
transparent
comparator
function
object
onu bir
yazalım
şimdi gerçekten
biraz karmaşık
arkadaşlar
öyle bir
hile yapılmalı
ki
bu hile de
buraya dikkat
bizim
küçüktür
operatörü
name lookup
kurallarına
uygun şekilde
bir
karşılaştırma
fonksiyonunun
olması gerekecek
şimdi onun için
diyorlar ki
aslında yapmam
gereken şu
bakın bu iki
fonksiyon yine var
yanlış anlaşılmasın
sonuçta
intle
karşılaştırmayı
bu fonksiyonlar
yapacak
ama sette de ben
neş türünden
nesneler tutuyorum
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şöyle bir sınıf
oluşturmamız
gerekiyor
ama bunun
hazırı da var
strut
diyelim ki
transparent
cmp
buna bir tane
karşılaştırma
fonksiyonu
vereceğiz
template
izleyin
type name t
type name u
yani iki tane
template
parametresi var
ve
bul
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
buraya dikkat
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalarına
trf
ref
diyelim ki
l as
sol operant
u ref
arkadaşlar
r h z
sağ operant
ve şimdi bakın
dedim ya
bir hayli karmaşık
perfect forwarding yapacağım
stut forward
l h s
küçük
stut forward
r h s
burası perfect forwarding kısmı
yani sağ taraf değeri de
sol taraf değeri de
kabul edecek
ve bunun
geri dönüş değerini
ürettiği değeri
geri dönüş
değeri yapıyorum
farkince izleyin
ben anlamadığınız
yeri tekrar
edeceğim
gereğinden fazla
karmaşık
yalnız diyor ki
buradaki
arama fonksiyonunun
bulunması için
şöyle bir
koşul koymuşlar
isim aramayla
burada
bu sınıfın
is transparent
isimli
bir nested
type olacak
bu nested
type'ın ne
olduğunun
önemi yok
yani hangi
türün eş
ismi olduğunun
hiçbir önemi yok
yani şöyle bir şey
yazabiliriz
using is transparent
eşittir
arkadaşlar
void
yani void türün
intüre
bu tür zaten
kullanılmayacak
şimdi artık
karşılaştırma
gerektiğinde
bu fonksiyon
bulunacak
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
yani ben
my set'in
find'ına
şimdi
örneğin
12 argümanını
geçersem
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ve bunu da
komparatör türü
yaparsam
set'in
net virgül
transparent
cmf
şimdi gördüğünüz gibi
kod
legal oldu
ama bakın
bunun legal olması
için
oluşturduğunuz
function object
type'ın
is transparent
isimli bir
nested type'ı
olması gerekiyor
şimdi dikkat
arkadaşlar
peki ne olacak
bu durumda
karşılaştırma
gerektiğinde
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyon
çağrılacak
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bu fonksiyona
siz
bir parametresine
my set'i
diğer parametresine
örneğin
int değeri
geçtiğinde
arkadaki kod
burada
aslında
küçüktür operatörün
operanda yapılmış
olacak ama
küçüktür operatörünün
operanda yapılan
ifade
aslında
set'te tutulan
değer
ve int
zaten sizin de
böyle bir fonksiyonunuz
var
bu durumda
bu fonksiyonlar
çağrılacak
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
işte bakın
buradaki
transparent
cmp
zero copy
oldu
stut forward
sayesinde
kısmı
arkadaşlar
zaten
fonksiyonun
parametresi
universal
referans
emiran
stut forward
kısmı
perfect forwarding
daha sorumlu
yani
l value
olarak
r value
olarak alıyor
yani bu fonksiyona
l value
da gelmiş olabilir
r value
biz herhangi bir yere
bunu kopyalamıyoruz
sadece küçüktür operatörün
operanda yapıyoruz
dolayısıyla
neyin çağrılmasını
sağlıyoruz
buradaki fonksiyonların
çağrılmasını
sağlıyoruz
buraya kadar
anlaşıldı mı
ama
işte
burada
böyle
struct
transparent
cmp
isimli
benim örneğimde
böyle bir
function object
type
oluşturmak
yerine
zaten
bu amaçla
kullanılan
standart kütüphanenin
bir
function object
type var
yine less
ama less'in
void açılımı
yani buraya
şöyle yazarsanız
zaten
işte onun
operatör
fonksiyonu
benim
az önce
gösterdiğim
transparent
cmp'nin
eş değeri
bu şu demek
eğer buradaki
detayları
üstünden
bir iki kere
geçmeniz gerekiyor
eğer buradaki
detayları
hiç anlamadıysanız
yapmanız gereken
son derece
basit
karşılaştırmayı
intle mi
yapmak
istiyorsunuz
ama sette
tutulan
öe
int mi
değil
o zaman
iki tane
global
operatör fonksiyonu
tanımlayın
bunlar
karşılaştırmayı
gerektiği gibi
yapsın
ve ondan sonra
arkadaşlar
seti
eğer bu tür
karşılaştırma
yapılacaksa
yani ekleme
silme
vesaire
işlemleri
böyle yapılacaksa
setin
nece açılımı
değil
arkadaşlar
lessin
void
açılımını
kullanıyorsunuz
zaten burada
default template
argümanı
void
bu durumda
karşılaştırmayı
böyle yapıyorsunuz
önemsiz gibi
görünüyor ama
maliyet açısından
çok önemli
bir fark var
çünkü
eğer ben
söyleyatsaydım
setin
arkadaşlar
nece açılımı
deseydim
karşılaştırmada
ne kullanmam
gerekecekti
nec nesnesini
kullanmam
gerekecekti
o zaman da
necin
küçüktür
operatör fonksiyonu
çağırılacaktı
evet
bu gerçekten
çok iyi
düşünülü
bu özellik
ve
eğer konuyu
daha detaylı olarak
incelemek
isterseniz
ben yine
bitaba
birkaç tane
örnek
koyacağım
yani çalışan
kod koyacağım
şimdi zaten
örnek gösterdim
ama
medya
aratın
transparent
function
object
necati
bu
global olarak da
kullanılabilir mi
evet
yine aynı şekilde
örneğin sıralı bir veri yapısında
vektör
vesaire
içinde
kullanabilirsiniz
standart kütüphanemizin
bize verdiği
arkadaşlar
böyle
transparent
function
objektler var
mesela bakınız
functional
başlık dosyasını
dahil edelim
tut
less
görüyor musunuz
less'in
int virgül
void açılımı
less'in neden
void açılımı olsun ki
Emran değil mi
less'in int açılımı
operatör fonksiyonu
iki
inti
küçüktür
karşılaştırmasına
sokuyor
ama
less'in
void açılımı
neden böyle yapsın
ama bakın şimdi
less'in void açılımını
gördünüz mü
is transparent
üyesi var
yani bir zaten
function objectin
transparent
function
object olup
olmadığını
anlamak
istiyorsanız
is
transparent
type
olup
olmadığına
bakacaksınız
örneğin
greater'ın
arkadaşlar
void açılımını
görüyorsunuz
is
transparent
biraz burası
karmaşık
kabul etmek
gerekiyor
ama
sanırım
anlaşılmasında
bir engel
olmadı
şimdi efendim
hemen
set'in
bu sefer
geçen
derste
global
algoritma
karşılıklarını
gördüğümüz
lower bound
upper bound
ve
equal range
fonksiyonlarını
görelim
tabi bunu
görmek için
bizim
neye
multi set
kullansak
daha iyi olur
multi set'in
int açılımı
my set
random fill
40 tane
irons
aralığında
değer
ve
jprint
my set
arkadaşlar
int
i
see out
enter the key
see in key
auto
iter
eşittir
bu sefer
bakın
üye fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
değişen bir şey yok
if
my set'in
lower bound
ne döndürüyordu
arkadaşlar
bu key'in
eklenebileceği
ilk konu
eklemenin
eklemenin yapılabileceği
ilk konu
eğer şöyle yazsaydım
iter
upper
upper bound
beklemenin yapılabileceği
son konu
ve
x'e birden
ihtiyacım
varsa
artık
biliyoruz
auto
lower
upper
bunlar
iteratör
ya da aynı
ismi
kullanayım
iter
lower
upper
eşittir
my set'in
equal
range'i
key
bu equal
range'de
sadece
key'ler var
equal
range'i
dolaşırsam
key'leri
dolaşmış
olurum
arkadaşlar
şimdi burada
şöyle bir yanlış
anlama da oluyor
tipik olarak
Necati ben
equal range'i
dolaştığımda
zaten key'ler var
neden dolaşayım
ki orayı
arkadaşlar
anahtar
az önceki örnekten
de görüldüğümüz
gibi
gördüğümüz gibi
set'in
karşılaştırma
kriteri
set'in
bütün öğeleriyle
ilgili olmak
zorunda
değil ki
yani örneğin
bunlar
my set'in
ya da
fighter
açılımı
vardır
arkadaşlar
ama
fighter'lar
örneğin
anahtar olarak
fighter'ın bir özelliği
kullanılmaktadır
fakat siz
my set'e
o aralığı
dolaştığınız zaman
onların hepsi
aynı değerde
değil ki
sadece
karşılaştırma
olarak
onlar
ekib
alandı
mesela bu
savaşçının
efendim
diyelim ki
ismi olsaydı
evet bir isimden
bir tane
olabilir
diyebilirdik
ama
arkadaşlar
başka özellikleri
setse bir isimden
bir tane olacak
mat setse birden
fazla olacak
ama
savaşçı sadece
bir isimden
ibaret değil ki
örneğin onun
güçü
silahı
vesaire
başka özellikleri de
var
yani orayı
dolaşıp
diğer özelliklerinden
de faydalanabilirim
diğer özelliklerini
de kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
böylece
şöyle bir
bakalım
değinmediğimiz
fonksiyon kaldı
mı
emplace
fonksiyonlarında
bir şeye dikkat
insertün karşılığı
emplace
ama bir de
arkadaşlar
hint parametreyle
hint insert
vardı ya
yani iteratör
konumu istiyordu
onu hint
ipucu olarak
alıyordu
onun karşılığı
olarak da
emplace
hint isimli
fonksiyon var
yani
emplace
fonksiyonları
bizden
doğal olarak
arkadaşlar
sette tutulacak
öğenin
constructorına
geçilecek
argümanları
istiyor
ama
emplace
hint
yine
tıpkı
insertte
olduğu gibi
bizden
ne istiyor
bir konum
örneğin
mysetin
bagini
ama yine
perfect board
edilecek
diğer
öğeleri
istiyor
mesela
şöyle
olsaydı
yine
date
başlık
dosyası
myset'in
date
açılımı
hint
fonksiyonu
olmasaydı
sadece
date'in
konstruktörüne
gönderilecek
argümanları
geçecektim
ama
diğeri için
emplace
hint
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
örneğin
myset'in
begin'i
konumunu
emplace
hint'e
argüman olarak
veriyorum
ve
böylece
set ve
multi-set
grubunu
tamamlamış
oluyoruz
ama yine de
bakalım
arkadaşlar
konuşmadığımız
fonksiyon kaldı mı
tabi
bütün
konteynerlarda
olan
clear fonksiyonunu
anlatmama
gerek yok
areas
all
contains'i
gördük
arkadaşlar
count'u
gördük
iterator fonksiyonlarını
biliyoruz
emplace
hint'i
gördük
empty'i
biliyoruz
equal
range
arrays
extract
find
ya da
locator
insert
insert range
buna değinmeyeceğim
çünkü
ranges
kütüphanesiyle
ilgili
keycomp
bunlardan
bahsedeceğim
lower bound
max size
merge
merge kaldı
ama merge'i herhalde
tahmin etmeniz çok kolay
nasıl listede
merge
ne işe yarıyorsa
burada da o işe yarıyor
arkadaşlar
yani
bir setteki
öğeleri
başka bir sete
katıyor
tabi yine
destruction olmayacak
hadi merge'i de bir gösterelim
bir tek o kaldı zaten
daha önce gördüğümüz
fonksiyonların dışında
mesela bakın
set'in
string açılımı
efendim
x
ayşe
nuri
berk
utku
kaya
set'in
string açılımı
y
melek
aysel
erkan
yeter
x'in
merge'ü
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
y
ne olacak
y'deki
öğeleri
oradaki
nottan çıkartacak
ekstrakt edecek
yani aslında
öğeleri destroy etmiyor
y'nin sayısını
sıfıra çekecek
yani y'de
öğe kalmayacak
y'yi
x'e katacak
dolayısıyla
arkadaşlar
ayşe
nuri
berk
utku
kaya'ydı
şimdi ne olacak
ayşe
lexical
compare olduğuna göre
ayşe
aysel
berk
erkan
kaya
melek
olacak
her ikisini de
yazdıralım
önce
c print
x
y
ve
merge'den sonra
c print
x
kaan can
diyor ki
hint insert
için
set örneğin
ağacın soluna
eklemek için
ağacın sağında
bir itaratör
verme
durumunda
kaan
ağacın
sağlı
solunu
biz
bilmiyoruz
o
implementasyon
tarafında
bizi
ilgilendiren
değerce
büyüklüğü
küçüklüğü
yani
örneğin
biz
setimizde
ayşe
berk
kaya
nuri
utku
olduğunu
biliyorsak
buraya
dikkat
insert
edeceğimiz
örneğin
kaya'nın
konumu
elimizde ise
buraya
örneğin
ne diyelim
kadan önce
ne gidiyor
diyelim ki
buraya
canı
ekleseydim
şu durumda
kaya'nın
konumunu
hint insert
olarak
verebilirdim
ama
aksi halde
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir
maniyet
artışı
olacağını
düşünmüyorum
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
yani
a'nın
sağa solu
meselesi
implementasyon
tarafını
ilgilendiriyor
bizi ilgilendiren
onun
değerce
küçüklüğü
arkadaşlar
şöyle
şaşırtmalı
bir soru
sorabilirler
bunu belki
ikinci kez
tekrar ediyorum
ama
emran çelik
unique
olmak zorunda
mı
unique
olmak zorunda
değil
unique
değilse
eğer setse
zaten yine
ekleme işlemi
yapılmayacak
yani
hint insert'ü
kullanmanız
setse
aynı öğeden
bir tane daha
ekleyebileceğiniz
anlamına
yine gelmiyor
yine ekleme
yapılırsa
yapılmazsa
zaten yine
geri dönüş
değerinden
eklemenin
yapılıp
yapılmadığını
anlayabilirsiniz
peki
şimdi
bir de
şundan
bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bakınız
generic
programlama
tarafında
container'ların
nested
type'ları
önem taşıyor
mesela
container'ların
hepsinin
örneğin
setin
int açılımının
value type'ı
var
bir container'ın
value type'ı
container'da
tutulan
öğenin
türü
yani
setin
int açılımının
value type'ı
int
ama
vektörün
int açılımının
value type'ı
da int
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
bazı
fonksiyonlar
tane
adet
ya da
bazı durumlarda
index belirten
fonksiyonlar
onların
türü de
fonksiyonlar
onların istediği
türde
size type
yani
container'ların
value type'ı var
size type'ı var
bakın
negatif değer
olabilecek
difference type'ı
var
container'ın
reference type'ı
arkadaşlar
container'da
tutulan
öğeye referans
türü
yani
setin
int açılımının
reference type'ı
int
ref
ya da
vektörün
int açılımının
reference type'ı
int
ref
türü
const
reference
türü
constant
ref
türü
ve yine aynı şekilde
bakın
pointer
türü var
setin
int açılımının
pointer
türü
arkadaşlar
int
yıldız
türü
setin
string açılımının
pointer türü
string yıldız
türü
gibi
böyle neler var
nested type'lar
var
ama bakın
sette
setin
int açılımının
bu türlere
bakın
key type
anahtarın
türü
yine
set olduğu için
anahtarın
türü
arkadaşlar
var
izleyin
auto
y eşittir
x
y'nin türüne
bakın
int
dolayısıyla
key type
setin key type'ı
yine sette tutulan
ö'nin türü
takip edebiliyor muyuz
arkadaşlar
ama bakın yine
burada ne var
key
compare
key type'ı
türü
anahtarı
karşılaştırmada
kullanılan tür
mesela
söyleyin bakalım
şöyle bir
nesne
oluştursaydım
arkadaşlar
efendim
key type'ı
veren
komisyon var
işte oradan
buraya geldik
zaten
auto
f
eşittir
my set'in
int açılımı
set'in int açılımı
my set
auto
f eşittir
şu fonksiyonlar
kalmıştı
my set'in
key kompu
ne veriyor
karşılaştırma
kriteri olan
türü
dolayısıyla
my set'in
key kompunun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
less'in
int açılımı
mesela set'in
int virgül
greater'ın
int açılımı
olsaydı
key komp ne
döndürecekti
greater'ın
int açılımını
döndürecekti
ama
arkadaşlar
ortak bir
arayüz
oluşturmak için
value komp da
var
fakat
set'te
key kompla
value komp
aynı
çünkü set'te
key'e karşılık
key tutuluyor
ayrı bir value
değeri yok
dolayısıyla
bir set'in
key komp fonksiyonunu
çağırsanız da
set'te
tutulan
anahtarın
karşılaştırma
türünü elde ediyorsunuz
value kompu
karşılaştırsanız da
yine aynı
türü elde ediyorsunuz
yani geri dönüş
değeri aynı
türden
münesne
ama birazdan
görmeye
başlayacağımız
map sınıfında
böyle değil
çünkü map
pair tutuyor
pair'in
first'u
bizim
anahtarımız
pair'in
second'ı
anahtara karşılık
gelen
value'umuz
o zaman biz
şimdi set'i
bitirmiş olduk
hemen
neye geçeceğiz
bizi biraz daha
zorlayacak
ama en az
set kadar önemli
map ve
multi-map
konteynerlarını
göreceğiz
saat 21.05
diyelim
bir ara veriyoruz
21.25'te
map
konteynerlarıyla
devam ediyoruz
arkadaşlar
map ile
set
aslında
veri yapısı
olarak aynı
aradaki
fark ne
map
key value
pair'leri
tutuyor
yani
map'te
tutulan
öğeler
birer
pair
oysa
set'te
tutulan
öğeler
sadece
key
yani
map'te
her key'e
karşılık
gelen
bir
value var
yine
bir
komparatör
var
yine
key'leri
karşılaştırıyor
fakat
eklediğimiz
zaman
key value
pair
ekliyoruz
aramayı
yine
key ile
yapıyoruz
ama
arama
karşılığı
bulduğumuz
yine
bir
key
value
pair
işte
burada
map'i
iyi anlayabilmek
iyi kullanabilmek
için
belirli
seviyede
stud pair'i de
bilmek
gerekiyor
çünkü
sonuçta
map'te
tutulan
öğeler
az önce
söylediğim gibi
birer
pair
hemen
map'in
nasıl bir
konteyner olduğunu
görmeye
başlayalım
başlık dosyası
map
nasıl
set ve
multi set isimli
iki ayrı
konteynerımız
varsa
map ve
multi
map isimli
iki ayrı
konteynerımız
var
aradaki
fark yine
aynı
map
bir keyden
bir tane
tutabilirken
multi
map
birden fazla
tutabiliyor
yalnız bir şey
dikkat
arkadaşlar
value'lar
aynı
olabilir
keylerin
farklı olması
gerekiyor
map'te
ama
multi
map'te
aynı keyden
birden fazla
olabilir
arkadaşlar
nasıl bir
template
bakın son derece
basit
mapping
birinci template
parametresi
key'in türü
ikinci template
parametresi
anahtarın türü
value'nun türü
özür dilerim
key zaten
anahtar
map'in
key
virgül
value
açılımı
üçüncü
template
parametresi
yine
komparatörün
türü
örneğin
less'in key
açılımı
yalnız son
parametresi
dikkat
hep
allocator'ın
default argümanı
olarak
allocator
oluyordu ya
allocator'ın
container'da
tutulan
öz
specialization'ı
ama burada
container'da
tutulan
artık
arkadaşlar
key değil
pairing
key value
açıldı mı
o zaman
map'in
arkadaşlar
nasıl bir
template olduğunu
artık
anlayabiliriz
şu
göstergemizi
de
açalım
ve
bakın
tek tek
template
parametrelerine
karşılık gelen
argümanlara
bakalım
birinci
template
argümanı
anahtarın
türü
örneğin
map'in
int açılımında
key'lerimiz
int olacak
aramayı
intle
yapacağız
eklerken
intler
karşılaştırılacak
arkadaşlar
evet
ekleme
arama
silme
işlemlerinde
karşılaştırma
hep
key'e göre
yapılacak
fakat
her key'e
karşılık gelen
bir value
var
arkadaşlar
efendim
value
örneğin
yine
aynı
tür olabilir
int'i
int'e
map'leyebilirsiniz
int'i
string'e
map'leyebilirsiniz
mesela
map'in
int virgül
string
açılımı
ne demek
aramayı
int'le
yapıyorum
ama
int'e
karşılık
bir
string'e
erişiyorum
mesela
kişilerin
numarasından
isme
erişmek
gibi
arkadaşlar
tabii ki
burada
key türünün
eğer
üçüncü
template
parametresi
olarak
less'in
int
açılımını
yani
less'in
key
açılımını
kullanıyorsak
ki bu
default
template
argümanı
ne olması
gerekiyor
less'le
karşılaştırılabilir
olması
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
yine son
parametrenin
pair'in
const
key
ve
value
açılımına
sahip
allocator
türü
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
yani
aslında
biz
çoğunlukla
şöyle
yazacağız
map'in
int
virgül
string
açılımı
yani
birinci ve
ikinci
template
parametresine
karşılık
gelen parametrelerine
gelen
template
argümanlarını
kullanacağız
ama
bu ne
demek
aslında
şöyle
onu da
alta yazalım
şunu yorum
satırına
alalım
embell
less'in
int virgül
string virgül
map'in
int virgül
string virgül
less'in
int virgül
allocator'ın
arkadaşlar
pair'in
const
int virgül
string
açılımı
böyle bir
türden
bahsediyorum
geçerli peki
map'i dolaşırken
iteratör konumundaki
öyeler birer
pair
değil mi
kesinlikle
ve karşılaştırma
ilişkisine
dolaştığımıza
göre
örneğin
int string
map'inde
biz
int'lerin
küçüklükten
büyüklüğüne
göre
dolaşmış
olacağız
hadi bakalım
şu map'e
biraz öyekleyelim
random
field
ama ilk önce
şöyle yapalım
arkadaşlar
öyeklemeyi
nasıl yapacağız
şimdi yine
aynı şekilde
map'te
bir anahtardan
birden fazla
olamaz
aynı anahtar
olduğunda
eklenmeyecek
ama matematte
birden fazla
olabilir
sınıfın
ekleme fonksiyonu
yine aynı şekilde
arkadaşlar
insert fonksiyonu
ama başka
insert fonksiyonları
da var
aşağıda zaten
görüyorsunuz
insert fonksiyonu
bizden
doğrudan
map'te
tutulacak
öğeyi istiyor
map'te
tutulacak
öğeyi de
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
bir
nedir
pair'dir
dolayısıyla
insert fonksiyonuna
bir pair
geçmemiz
gerekiyor
ne pair'i
geçeceğiz
pair'in
int string
açılımı
arkadaşlar
şimdi özellikle
modern
C++'la gelen
araçlar söz konusu
olduğunda
insert işlemi
yapmak için
elimizde
çok sayıda
seçenek var
bakın
birincisi
doğrudan
siz
elinizde bu türden
bir nezle vardır
örneğin
stup pair'in
int virgül
string açılımı
P1
Süleyman
insert fonksiyonuna
doğrudan
P1
nesnesine
geçebilirsiniz
ya da
bir başka
değer nesneniz
vardır
P2
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanabilirsiniz
mesela
arkadaşlar
maciye
maresetin
insert'ü
efendim
stup
move
P2
doğrudan
bir pair
geçici nesnesi
verebilirsiniz
my map'in
insert'ü
arkadaşlar
efendim
pair
geçici nesnesi
oluşturuyorum
ve sitat'tan
faydalanıyorum
ve diyelim ki
pur
good
derliyorum
herhangi bir hata yok
hatta hatta
arkadaşlar
employees
moksununu
çağırabilirim
my set'in
employees'i
bu durumda
my map'in
özür dilerim
employees'i
constructor'a
gönderilecek
argümanları
göndereceğim için
örneğin
saving
ama
bunun dışında
C++
standardı ile
gelen
ama
biraz daha
sonra
göreceğimiz
insert or
assign
try
employees
fonksiyonları
da var
dolayısıyla
insert fonksiyonlarına
çağrı yapabilirim
ve
and place
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
make pair
afrika fonksiyonunu
kullanabilirim
mesela
make pair
necati
buradan elde ettiğim
r value olan
pair'i
doğrudan
my set'in
insert
fonksiyonuna
argüman
my set
ve my map'in
insert
fonksiyonuna
argüman olarak
gönderebilirim
yani
insert etmenin
birden fazla
yolu var
şimdi
set'i dolaşırken
a
normal
iteratör döngüsü
kullanabilirim
b
yine
range
base
kullanabilirim
ki o da
bir iteratör
döngüsü
demek
yalnız
burada bir
şeye dikkat edelim
arkadaşlar
map'teki
üyeler
birer pair
olduğu için
eğer siz
şu şekilde
dolaşırsanız
const
auto
ref
my map
burada
döngünler
durumda
p
bir pair
dolayısıyla
first'üne
erişmek
için
see out
p'nin
first'ü
unstreaming
load
edelim
şimdilik
bir formatlama
yapmıyorum
ve
p'nin
second'ı
bakın
şimdi
nasıl ulaştığıma
tabi ki
isimlerin
küçükten
büyüklüğüne
göre
intlerin
anahtar
oysa
şöyle olsaydı
görüyorsunuz
necati
naciye
şimdi ben
buraya
şöyle bir
insert
çağrısı
daha
yapsaydım
efendim
elvan
bu
ekleme
gerçekleşmeyecekti
çünkü
olduğu için
daha önce
ama
multi
map
olsaydı
ekleme
yapılacaktı
şimdi
map yerine
multi
map yapalım
arkadaşlar
yine
multi
map'in
int string
virgül
greater'ın
int açılımı
olsaydı
bu
seferde
anahtarlar
büyükten
küçüğü
olacak
şekilde
dolaşacaktım
yani
komparatör
olarak
greater
dolayısıyla
büyüktür
operatörü
kullanılacaktı
bir soru var
galiba
pair'siz
insert
ettiğimizde
pair'i
null
mı oluyor
şimdi
pair'in
null
olması
diye bir şey
zaten
söz konusu
değil
pair'siz
insert
etmem
de
söz konusu
değil
olsan
zaten
sizin sorunuzun
cevabını
şimdi
vereceğim
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
insert
fonksiyonu
yok zaten
bakın
emiran
mymap'in
insert'ü
böyle bir
çağrı
yapamazsınız
çünkü
insert sizden
container'da
tutulacak
üe
türünden
bir değer
istiyor
ya da
ona dönüştürülecek
türden
ama
eğer
sorucuysa
emiran
emplace
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
emplace
fonksiyonu
argüman göndermeden
çağırdığınızda
sınıfın
default
constructor'ını
çağırıyor
default
constructor'ı
da
pair'i
value
initialize
ediyor
value
initialize
etmesi
ne demek
tam sayı
değerler için
sıfır
ama
arkadaşlar
stringler için
default
constructor
çağırılacak
yani
bütün
arkadaşlarıma
söylüyorum
sadece
emiran için
değil
böyle bir
emplace
çağrısı
yapsaydım
map'e ne koymuş
olurdum
key'i
sıfır
ve
arkadaşlar
values'u
boş string olan
bravo
olsan
evet
tabi şimdi
string'e yazdırdığım için
orada bir şey
görmeyeceğiz
ama en azından
ama zaten
emplace'i
çağırmamışım
çağırayım
evet
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
küçükten
büyüğü
olsaydı
da
sıfır
başta
olacaktı
şimdi
tam ben
söyleyecektim
oğuzhan
bey'e de
sormuş
arkadaşlar
özellikle
map'le
structure
binding'le
dolaşma
çok daha
yaygın
ama
oğuzhan
hemen burada
bir
açıklama da
yapalım
bu map
olmasından
dolayı
değil
mesela
vektörün
pair açılımı
olsaydı da
öyle dolaşabilirdim
önce bunu bir
structure binding'e
bir gönderme yapalım
önce bunu
structure binding'le
dolaşalım
const
autoref
diyelim ki
aslında bizim
intlerimiz
anahtarlarımız
numara
öbürü de
isim
bakın bu şekilde
dolaşıp
artık
no'yu
ve name'i
doğrudan
kullanabilirim
pair'in
first'ü
ve second'ı
yerine
ama bu
tekrar söylüyorum
map olması
nedeniyle
değil
arkadaşlar
container'da
tutulan
öenin
structure binding'e
uygun bir
tür olması
mesela şöyle
olsaydı
olur muydu
bir örnek
daha yapalım
bakınız
struct
data
int
x
y
z
10 tane
ö ekleyeceğim
ya da
100 tane
vektörün
data açılımı
myvek
vektör bağışlık
dosyasını
nail edin
ve
bak
myvek
pushback
data
nitriyeti
bağışlık
dosyasını
ekliyorum
i rent
my rent
pushback
data
my rent
şimdi
benim vektörüm
arkadaşlar
ne tutuyor
data
nesneleri
tutuyor
değil mi
şurası
küme parantezi
olacak
şimdi bunu
yine
structure binding'le
dolaşabilir miyim
tabii ki
nasıl ulaşacağım
for
örneğin
auto
xyz
ya da abc
isimler
önemli
my rent
structure
binding'i
ayrıntılı
olarak
anlatacağım
isterseniz
bir dahaki
derste
anlatayım
ama
ondan önce
bazı
başka
konuları
bilmemizde
fayda
var
işte
map'te
de böyle
tutulan
pair
olduğu için
yani
burada
mesela
vektörün
data
açılımı
yerine
vektörün
pair
açılımı
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
orada da
aynı şey
söz konusu
olacaktı
şimdi
önceki
koda
geri
dönelim
evet
bu sefer
map'in
multi
in string
açılımı
yapalım
ve
map'i
doldururken
bu sefer
biraz
kolaya
kaçayım
random
field
my
map
tane
ö
ama
lambda
ifadesi
kullanayım
generator
olarak
return
pair
arkadaşlar
int
string
int için
ayrent
ya da
string
içinde
neutrity
de ekleyelim
string
içinde
arkadaşlar
random
name
biraz karmışık oldu
ama
ben açıklayacağım
merak etmeyin
şimdi şu
pair
stat'tan
faydalanacağım
buradaki ifadenin
türü int
dolayısıyla
pair'in
int açılımı
olacak
buradaki ifadenin
türü
string
dolayısıyla
pair'in
arkadaşlar
int virgül
string açılımı
olacak
bu küme
parantezi
pair
constructor
parantezi
yani
geçeniyetini
oluşturma
küme
parantezi
efendim
burada
return
pair
bir noktalı
virgül
olacak
ondan
sonra
şu
lambda
ifadesinin
noktalı
virgülü
tam başka
bir eksik
yok
herhalde
şöyle bir
derleyelim
şimdi bu
arkadaşlar
multi map
olduğu için
biraz da
aralığı
daraltalım
mesela
olsun
şimdi
map'imizi
dolaşalım
for
const
auto
ref
int
o
yine
numarası
olsun
ya da
id olsun
bir şey
olsun
no
diğeri de
name
olsun
yine
structure
binding
den
faydalanıyorum
my
map
döngünler
turunda
da
yazdırayım
arkadaşlar
see you out
bakın
ilerleyen derslerde
format
kütüphanesine
geçersek
geçebilirsek
normalde
ileri
c++'tan
bakıyorum
stut format
c++20
ya da c++23
ile gelen
print'i
kullanabiliriz
o zaman çok kolay
formatla
formatlamak
şöyle yazacağım
format isimli
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
bu fonksiyon
bana bir
string döndürecek
ama
burada
printf
tarzı
arkadaşlar
formatlama
yapıyorum
ne yazdıracağım
bunu o için
bu da
name için
şimdi
sağa dayalı
sola dayalı
ayarlamasını
yapabiliyorum
mesela
arkadaşlar
efendim
10 karakterlik
alana
bu da
20 karakterlik
alana
ondan sonra da
bir new line
versin
format fonksiyonunun
geri dönüşte
yorulanı
stringi
yazdırıyorum
format kütüphanesi
ve formatlama
çok daha kolay
bir 2-3 saatte
öğrenebileceğim
zaten bilemediniz
4-5 saatte
iyi öğrenebileceğimiz
bir
kütüphane
evet
şu argümanları
yazmamışım
no
ve
name
evet
bakın
arkadaşlar
2 Süleyman
bir tane fazla
new line verdik
evet
2 Süleyman
şurada
şurada da
new line var ya
tamam
şimdi
multi map
olduğu için
anahtarlardan
birden fazla var
tabii ki
anahtar
bizim için
cost
ama value
cost değil
yani
herhangi bir
öğeye erişip
örneğin
şöyle bir kod
yazabilir miyim
my map
begin
bu iteratör
arkadaşlar
iteratör konumundaki
öğenin
second'ına eriştim
ve onun değerini
örneğin
kayhan
yaptım
iş mi engel yok
anahtarı değiştiremem
ama anahtara karşılık
gelen value'lar
const
değil
eğer bu
map'in
pamperse
string
int açılımı
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
şimdi de
bizim
key'imiz
string olacaktı
hatta
aynı kodu
kullanalım
fakat
şunların yerini
değiştirelim
evet
inerisi
kursu
şubat
ya da
mart'ta
kesin açılıyor
zaten şu anda
o kesinleşti
evet
arkadaşlar
bakın böyle
random
pair
ayrent
ve
bu sefer
tabii
neyle
anahtarımız
string olduğu için
less'in
arkadaşlar
şurayı da
değiştirelim
dedik
string int açılımı
tabii
less'in
string açılımı
kullanıldığı için
isimlerin
küçükten
büyüklüğüne
göre
dolaşacağım
bu sefer
tam tersi
şöyle
yazalım
name
no
normal
kısmına
bakmayın
orası
sadece
yazarken
formatlamak
için
evet
return
pair
bir yerde
yine bir
parantez
hatası var
random name
ayrent
fonksiyon çağrı
operatıdır
silinmiş
evet
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
abdi
abdülmutkalip
adnan
ahmet
yani
anahtar
burada
string
evet
tabi ben
yazdırırken
o sırayla
yazdırmadım
string int açılımı
no name
name
no
şurası ters
oldu
name
no
tamam
erleyip çalıştıralım
şimdi önemli olan
burada
neyi anlamak
map'te tutulan
öğeler
arkadaşlar
key
value
pair'i
insert
ederken
key value
pair'i
vermem gerekiyor
arama yaparken
key ile arama
yapacağım
ama
sonuçta
iteratör konumundaki
öğe
bulduğum
new value
pair'i
olacak
interface
neredeyse aynı
farklı olan yerleri
söyleyeceğim
mesela
map'in
insert fonksiyonu
yine ne döndürüyor
iteratör
bull pair'i
döndürüyor
map'in yine
emplace fonksiyonu
var mı
var
sadece
arkadaşlar
iteratör konumundaki
öğeler değişti
mesela
bakınız
bir arama işlemi
yapalım
string
şimdi anahtar
string olduğu için
string name
cout
öğe sayısını da
azaltalım
10 yapalım
cout
hatta yine
yazdıralım
c
print
my map
yalnız new line
yazsın
cout
aranacak
ismi girin
ismi
giriniz
string
name
see in
if
auto iter
ya arama fonksiyonları
yine aynı
if auto iter
eşit
my map'in
find'ı
name
arkadaşlar
iter
eşit değilse
my map'in
end'ı
demek ki
buldum
see out
bulundu
iter
nokta
first
iter ok
boşluk
second
derliyorum
evet
aranacak
ismi girin
if
bulundu
aranacak
ismi girin
aykut
bulundu
yani
anahtarla
arama yaptım
peki
necati
yine
count
fonksiyonu
efendim
contains
fonksiyonu
burada var mı
var
count da var
contains
de var
ve yine
aynı şekilde
extract
fonksiyonu
yine bize
not
handle
veriyor
hemen
yine
üretimde
çok
gerekeceği için
anahtar
değiştirmeyi
bu sefer
burada yapalım
bakın
bu da
yine
tipik
programcılara
sorulan
soru
izleyin
şimdi
yine
aynı şekilde
string
eski
ve
yeni
anahtarlar
girin
anlamında
eski ve yeni
anahtarı
girdim
şimdi
aramayı
yapıyorum
if
auto
iter
eşittir
my
mapping
find
old
key
iter
eşit
değil
my
map'in
end'i
ve
extract
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
my
map'in
extract'i
iter
geri dönüş
değerini
handle
değişkende
tutuyorum
auto
handle
eşittir
my
map'in
extract'i
şimdi
artık
burada
sefer
handle'ın
arkadaşlar
yine aynı fonksiyonları var
tek farkı
key
ve
mapped
elemanları var
key
anahtara
referans
veriyor
map'de
arkadaşlar
map fonksiyonunda
map edilmiş
yani
value'ya
referans
veriyor
dolayısıyla
şimdi ben
key'i
değiştirmek
için
handle'ın
key'i
eşittir
efendim
new key
görüyor musunuz
values'unu da
istersem
değiştirebilirim
ama değiştirmemeyi
tercih ediyorum
handle'ın key
new key
ve
arkadaşlar
bu arada
value'u değiştirmek
isteseydim
zaten doğrudan
değiştirebilirdim
hiçbir engel yok
ve tekrar
insert fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
my set'in
insert'ü
my map'in
ve
sağ taraf
değeri olarak
handle'ı
veriyorum
see out
değiştirildi
atmayalım
ve tekrar
j print fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
else
see out
bulunamadı
evet
mesela
emine
arkadaşlar
eski ve yeni
anahtarlar
emine
onun yerine
zeynep ekleyelim
evet bakın
emine
gitti
yerine
zeynep
geldi
burada yalnız
nested type'lar
önemli
arkadaşlar
set'in
birinci
map'in
birinci template
parametresine
karşılık gelen
tür
key type
yani örneğin
map'in
string int
açılımının
map'in
int virgül
string açılımının
key type'ı
buraya dikkat
string
map'in
string int
açılımının
arkadaşlar
map type'ı
mapped
yani
participle
mapped
type'ı
string
ama
söyleyin bakalım
map'in
int virgül
string açılımının
value type'ı
ne
bunu özellikle
belirtiyorum ki
key value
pair'i
diyoruz ya
value type'ın
int olduğunu
düşünüyorlar
hayır hayır
o map type
value type
her zaman
container'da
tutulan
öenin türü
container'da
ne tutuluyor
bravo olsam
pair'in
int
string açılımı
dolayısıyla
value type
pair'in
int
string açılımı
tekrar edelim mi
key type
string
arkadaşlar
map type
int
value type
pair'in
string
int
açılımı
diğer arama
fonksiyonlarımız
yine var
yani
arkadaşlar
count
fonksiyonu
anahtardan
kaç tane var
efendim
contains
fonksiyonu
var mı yok mu
boolean
döndürüyor
az önce gördüğümüz
find fonksiyonu
iteratör
döndürüyor
yine
diğer
konteynerlarda
olduğu gibi
iteratör
parametreli
erase
fonksiyonu
var
arkadaşlar
iteratör
çifti
range
parametreli
erase
fonksiyonu
var
bir de
key isteyen
yine
erase
fonksiyonu
var
örneğin
bir tanesini
en azından
gösterin
multi
map'in
int virgül
string
açılımı
bu sefer
tamam
string virgül
int
açılımı
100 bin
tane
değer
koyuyorum
yazdırmayacağım
örneğin
count
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
siyah
my map'in
count'u
key vereceğim
yani string
ya da string'e dönüşecek
değer vereceğim
ahmet
ama şimdi burada
lower bound
upper bound
equal ring
çok önemli
kazanacak
değil mi
mesela
bakınız
şöyle olsaydı
multi
map'in
string virgül
string açılımı
isimden
soy isme
gitseydim
binöe
eklemeye
çalışayım
tabii
multi
map olduğu için
ekleme yapılacak
my map'in
arkadaşlar
m play'si
bir arkadaşımın
mikrofonu açık
kalmış olabilir
my map'in
m play'si
efendim
iki tane
string
random name
random
surname
şimdi anahtar
isim olduğu için
isimlere göre
dolaşacak
değil mi
yani örneğin
şöyle bir
range base
for loop
yazsaydım
const
auto
ref
name
surname
my map
hatta
dosyamıza
yazalım
çıktığı
görmek için
şurada
out.txt
isimli
bir dosyam
var
fstream
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
ediyorum
out.txt
dosyasını
oluşturuyorum
ve çıkışı
oraya yapıyorum
ofs
name
surname
ya da bakın
nestle formatı
kullanalım
ofs
format
iki tane
V yazdıracağım
isim ve soy isim
bir de
new line
isim
sola dayalı
16 karakterlik
alana
su isimde
yine sola dayalı
arkadaşlar
20 karakterlik
alana
yazılsın
evet
şurayı
my map'in
emplay'si
random name
random
surname
alttan
nerede olduğuna
bakalım
evet
yine şeyleri
yazmamışız
klasik
formatın
argümanlarını
göndermemişim
name
surname
evet
alana
onu
atladım
şimdi
değerleyip
çalıştıralım
evet
bakın
şu anda
multi map'imiz
böyle
bunlar bizim
anahtarlarımız
multi map olduğu için
anahtardan birden fazla var
ama anahtara karşılık
eriştiğimiz
value'lar
ama şimdi
ben örneğin
lower bound
upper bound
equal range
fonksiyonlarıyla
aynı anahtara
sahip
fakat
farklı value'larla
eşlenecek
öğeleri
dolaşabilirim
şimdi
bakın
burası
kalsın
yine
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
isim
seçelim
mesela
ne var
engin
var en azından
tabi random
gerçek
ama önemli
değil
bize
auto
lower
upper
eşittir
my map'in
equal range
efendem
ne olsun
ad
ya da
engin
evet bu range'i
dolaşalım
arkadaşlar
ya da doğrudan
jprint fonksiyonuyla
ya da
böyle dolaşayım ki
bakın
for
ya da while
döngüsü
çok karar değiştirdik
arkadaşlar
bu da iteratör
o zaman şöyle yazabilirim
değil mi
while
lower
eşit
ya da
belki ayrı bir
iteratör değişken de
oluşturabilirsiniz
mesela for
auto
iter
eşittir
lower
iter
eşit değil
upper
artı artı
iter
tabi tipik olarak bu bir fonksiyon da
gizlenmiş olacak
see out
arkadaşlar
iter
first
second
önce equal range'deki
bütün öğeleri dolaştım
mesela
engin
kaplan
aksoy
engin
turgut
evet
iki tane varmış zaten
engin
zahimoğlu
elebaşı
ama
öğel sayısını
on bine çıkartalım
ve
equal range'imizi
dolaşalım
görüyorsunuz
engin
yaşayabaş
keskin
engin
temizel
bunlar
anahtar
anahtarlara
karşılık
gelen
value'lar
arkadaşlar
yalnız şimdi
map sınıfının
bizi biraz
zorlayacak bazı fonksiyonları var
onları da yavaş yavaş
görelim
efendim
önce
şunları
bir saklamak istiyorum
müsaadenizle
evet
şöyle bir fonksiyonların yine resmi geçirdiğini resmi geçirdiğini yapalım
arkadaşlar
my map
çok hızlı geçeceğim
begin c
clear
eraisal
contains
gördük
count
yani sette de var
cr begin c
rand
yine tabi ki
map'in de iteratörleri
arkadaşlar
bidirectional
iteratör kategorisinde
emplace
emplacent
empty
and
equal range
erase
extract
find
erase'in tabi
key desilinde var
değil mi
evet
get allocator
insert
insert range
key comp
lower bound
max size
merge
operator atama
r begin
rn
size
swap
upper bound
value comp
arkadaşlar
burada
yalnız dikkat
key comp fonksiyonu
anahtarı karşılaştıran
fonksiyon döndürüyor
yani o
türden bir değer döndürüyor
yani örneğin
map'in
string virgül
int virgül
less'in int
açılımının
key comp'u
less'in int
açılımını döndürecek
fakat
diğeri
bakın
şöyle yapalım
göstereyim
bakınız
auto x
eşittir
my map'in
key comp'u
less'in string
açılımı
auto x
eşittir
my map'in
value comp'u
arkadaşlar
bakınız
multi map'in
string string
açılımının
value
compare'i
türünden
yani
value'ları
karşılaştıran
tür
peki
devam
my map'in
başka fonksiyonları
kaldı mı
kalmadı
burada
kritik bir fonksiyon
var
belki diğer
programlama dillerinde
benzerini
görmüşsünüzdür
ama biraz
dikkatli olmamız
gereken çok
önemli bir fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
ilginç bir şekilde
map sınıfının
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
var
ve çok işe yarıyor
ama çok da
dikkatli kullanmak
gerekiyor
şimdi
diyelim ki
map'in
ne olsun
string virgül
int
açılımı
olsun
yine
my map
ve
sayıda
v ekleyelim
efendim
10 kez dönen
bir döngü içinde
my map
m place
random
name
ve
diyelim ki
bu sefer
c'deki
run fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
ya da
kendi run fonksiyonumuzu
çağıralım
iron
burayı biraz daha
dikkatli izlememiz
gerekecek
c print
my map
arkadaşlar
pair'in
pair'i yazdıran
benim
utility de fonksiyonum
olduğu için
c print'te
doğrudan
çalışacak
çünkü
pair'in
insörter'ını
ben yazdım
yoksa
syntax hatası
olurdu
zaten
dikkat ederseniz
köşeli parantez
içinde yazmasının
nedeni
bizim daha önce
yazdığımız
pair
sınıf şablonu
için yazdığımız
insörter
şimdi dikkat
arkadaşlar
bakınız
eğer siz
map nesnesinde
yalnız
multi map'te yok
sadece map'te var
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonunu
operanda yaparsanız
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonuna
argüman olarak
yani köşeli parantezin
içine yazdığınızı
hatırlayalım
bir value değeri
verirseniz
key değeri
özür dilerim
örneğin
my map
arkadaşlar
ne olsun
emre
eşittir
şimdi çok
dikkatli izleyin
burada
çağrılan fonksiyon
şunu yapıyor
herkes dikkatli izliyor
biraz karmaşık
eğer
bu anahtar
map'te var ise
arkadaşlar
bu ifade
sizi
o map'te olan
ue'nin
values'una
eriştiriyor
yani bu
value'a referans
böylece
arkadaşlar
ne yapmış
oluyorsunuz
iyi
bu olanın
values'unu
değiştirmiş
oluyorsunuz
ondan yazalım
eğer
key
map'te
var ise
mevcut
ise
arkadaşlar
o
ki'ye
karşılık
gelen
value'ya
eriş
dolayısıyla
o value'yu
değiştir
ama
buraya dikkat
eğer
key
map'te
yok ise
yani
emre
örneğin
map'te
yok ise
buraya dikkat
tarlan fonksiyon
şöyle bir
key value
pair
oluşturacak
arkadaşlar
key'i
fonksiyona
gönderdiğim
argüman
values'u
default
construct edilmiş
bir
value
özür dilerim
value initialize edilmiş
bir value
değeri
iki kere value
geçti ama
yanlış kullanmadım
value initialize
bir terim
arkadaşlar
ve
sizi
onu sete
insert edecek
ve
insert edilmiş
öğenin
yine
values'una
eriştirecek
yani
emre yoksa
şöyle bir işlem
yapıldığını
düşünün
arkadaşlar
my map
insert
emre
yok ise
efendim işte
pair'in
string int
açılımı
ama
pair'in
string int
açılımında
arkadaşlar
string'i
emre
olacak
sembolik
olarak
yazıyorum
ona karşılık
gelen value
sıfır olacak
neden
sıfır
olacak
çünkü
value initialize
ediliyor
ve
bunun
nesne
eriştirecek
sizi
arkadaşlar
insert edilen
nesnenin
hatta
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
diğerinin
insert edilmiş
öğe'ye
iteratör olduğunu
düşünürseniz
onu kendinize
yazabilirsiniz
insert edilmiş
öğenin
values'una
eriştirecek
bu da şu
demek
fiilen
hiç bu
uzun açıklamayı
yapmadan
siz böyle
bir kodla
ne diyorsunuz
emre varsa
values'unu
76 yap
emre yoksa
emre
76 pair'i
ne
ekle
espri anladınız mı
ve tabi
çok yerde
kullanılıyor
hemen bir örnek
yapalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
string name
int
while
print
see out
isim
ve
numara
girin
numarayı da
biraz
aralığını
genişletelim
see in
name
while
şimdi bakın
my map
name
eşittir
while
ve
tekrar
konteyneri
yazdırıyorum
şimdi
run time'a
bakınız
arkadaşlar
örneğin
ben
hakkı
deseydim
olduğu için
map'teki
bu
PR erişecekti
bizi onun
values'una
eriştirecekti
dolayısıyla
şuradaki
kod
hakkının
values'unu
neredeydi o
evet burada
hakkının
values'unu
while
değeri
yapacaktı
girdiğimiz
while
değeri ne
hakkı
örneğin
bakın
tekrar
yazdırdım
ve
ekran çıktısını
şöyle büyütelim
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
hakkı
idi
oldu
ama
şimdi
daha rahat
görülsün
diye
5'e
düşüreyim
ve
tekrar
çalıştırayım
evet bakın
önce var
olmaya bir örnek
devrimin
values'unu
yapalım
bakın
devrim
198'di
oldu
ama
şimdi
bakın
isim ve
numara
girin
isim
deniz
numara
deniz var mı
yok
o zaman
bir p
ekleyecek
insert edecek
ki deniz
olacak
aslında
values'u
sıfır
olacak
ama
bizim yaptığımız
atamayla
biz values'unu
yapmış olacağız
bu da ne demek
deniz
eklenmiş olacak
görüyorsunuz
deniz
şimdi bu neden önemli
arkadaşlar
hem üretimde
çok sık
kullanmanız
gerekebilecek
hem de yine
mülakatlarda
sorulan
çok tipik bir
soru var
MEP'in
en tipik
kullanım
biçimine
işaret ediyor
ya da
en tipik
kullanımlarından
birine
karşılık geliyor
izleyin şimdi
diyorlar ki
size
elinizde
bir veri yapısı
var
mesela
bir vektör
örneği
baştan sona
çok dikkatli
izlemenizi
isteyeceğim
vektörün
diyelim ki
string açılımı
svek
ve burada
random
fill
svek
10.000
tane
isim var
bu pekala
başka bir konu
list olabilirdi
deck olabilirdi
vektör olabilirdi
cdst olabilirdi
ve tutulan
string olabilirdi
tam sayı olabilirdi
vesaire
date olabilirdi
random fill
svek
10.000
random
name
diyorlar ki
ise
burada isimler var
bu örnek için
konuşuyorum
her isimden
kaç tane olduğunu
saymamız gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
yani hatta
şöyle bir
yazdıralım
isterseniz
ya da şimdilik
yazdırmayayım
mesela kaç tane
Ahmet var
kaç tane
Mehmet var
Hasan var
bu bilgiyi
elde etmem
gerekiyor
şimdi
idiomatik
koda bakın
biraz şaşırtıcı
çok taşık
bir tane
map oluşturuyorsunuz
map'in
arkadaşlar
string
int açılımı
şimdi bu map'te
cmap ismini verdiğim
map'te
anahtar ne
Alihan
string
ona karşılık gelen
value ne
int
tahmin edin
cmap dedim
biraz daha uzun
isim verseydim
count map
falan gibi
isim verebilirdim
ne işe
yarayacak bu map
sayma işlemi
bittiğinde
map'teki
key
yani string
sayılan
değer
olacak
örneğin
Ahmet
ama inti de
Ahmet'ten
kaç tane
olduğu olacak
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
ama bakın
güzel olan
kısım şimdi
başlıyor
vektörü
dolaşıyorum
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi bakın
cmp
name'i
argüman olarak
verdim
ve bunu
artı artı
operatörün
operanda yaptım
ve sayma
işlemi
bitti
iki satır kod
ilk defa
böyle bir kodü
görenler
anlamakta zor
çekebiliyor
Allah Allah
nasıl olur
böyle bir iş
arkadaşlar son derece
basit
az önce ben size
subscript operator
function
benim türkçemle
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonunun
nasıl çalıştığını
söyledim
değil mi
diyelim ki
döngünün
name
ahmet
ama
şu anda bizim
cmp'imiz boş
olduğuna göre
ahmet'i ekleyecek
değil mi
varsa value'suna
eriştiriyordu
yoksa
ekleyip
eklenmiş
öğenin value'suna
eriştiriyordu
peki soru
eklenmiş
öğeyi
eklerken
value'yu
value initialize
ediyordu
intin value
initialize
edilmesi
sıfır
olması
demek
değerini
dolayısıyla
aslında bizi
buraya eklenmiş
cmp'e eklenmiş
ismin Ahmet olduğunu
söylemiştik
daha ilk eklemeden
bahsediyorum
Ahmet
sıfır
perinin
second'ına
referans yoluyla
eriştirecek
biz de o second'ı
bir arttırıp
bir yapmış olacağız
buraya kadar
anladınız mı
ama
döngünün
herhangi bir
turunda
name
tekrar
Ahmet
olduğunda
artık o
map'te olduğu için
bizi
onun
values'una
eriştirecek
onun values'u
diyelim
5 ise
6 olacak
1 ise
2 olacak
herkes anladı mı
yani Necat
şöyle değil mi
şimdi ben
map'i dolaşsam
ki bakın
tekrar söylüyorum
mülakatlarda da
sorulan böyle
çok klasik soru
programlama dilinden
de bağımsız olarak
şimdi bakınız
ben
map'i dolaşıyorum
for
const
string
ref
name
arkadaşlar
structure binding
name
count
ht
cmap
takip edebilirim
const string diyorum
auto
ref name count cmap
isterseniz yazdıralım
hatta
bir dosyaya yazdıralım
yine
ofs
name
ve
count
derleyip çalıştırıyorum
evet bakın
dosyaya şimdi
out.txt'ye
abdiden
formatlamaya bakmayın
abdiden 28 tane
abdullah'dan 31 tane
çok şık değil mi
fuattan 34 tane
kerimden
keremden 41 tane
kerimden 33 tane
oldu olacak
formatlamayı da
güzel yapalım
arkadaşlar
tut
format
zaten
using
bildirimi
format
bu
olsun
bunda herhangi bir
formatlama
gerekmiyor
new line
name
ve
count
etterleyip çalıştırıyorum
bu maple ilgili
tipik
idiomatik yapılardan
biri
out.txt'de
yani bir
konteynerda
ya da bir
rençte olan
öğeleri saymak
soruyu sorarken
şöyle sorarlarsa
dikkat edin
hemen bir çözüm
geliştirin
ben söylemeden
siz bana önerinizi
söyleyin
arkadaşlar
dikkat
isimleri istiyorum
ama
isimleri
alfabetik
alfabetik sırayla
değil
büyükten
köşeye
yani en fazla
örneğin
eda varsa
eda başta olacak
yazdırırken
hadi bakalım
güzel bir soru
nasıl yaparsınız
soruyu herkes
anladı mı
yani yine
isimleri sayacağım
ama listelerken
yani çıkışı
alırken
ben
map'i dolaştığım
için
map'te
arkadaşlar
string
int
map'i olduğu
için
şu saymam
yapayım
gördüğünüz gibi
dolaşırken
küçükten büyüğe
isimleri dolaştım
ben isimlerin
küçükten büyüklüğüne
göre değil
sayıların
büyükten
küçüklüğüne
göre görmek
istiyorum
mesela
Ayşe
140 tane
Tekin
120 tane
Alihan
bu
ama tam
predikat ile
ne yapacağız
problem orada
arkadaşlar
bunu yapmanın
en kolay
yollarından
biri şu
olabilir
birden fazla
yol
sizde
deneyin
bunu
örneğin
bir vektöre
Emirhan
diyor ki
karşılaştırma
a'nın
sekıntı
büyüktür
d'nin
sekıntı
ama
nerede
yapacaksınız
bunu
anladınız mı
şimdi
map üstünde
böyle bir
değişiklik
yapamazsınız
burada
ikinci bir
konteyner
kullanmak
en kolay
yol
bravo
Kaan Can'ın
ben çözümünü
hemen
şey yapabilirim
buradaki
o elleri
bir vektöre
taşırdım
yani çözümlerden
bir tanesi
bakın
vektörün
arkadaşlar
pair'in
string int
açılımı
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
vek
hatta
izleyin
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
range
constructor'ı
kullanayım
bakın range
constructor'ın da
önemini
bir güzelliğini
gösteriyor
gemep'in
begin'i
end'i
takip edebiliyor muyuz
aslında ben
arkadaşlar
buradaki
öğeleri
ne yapmış oldum
vektöre
taşımış oldum
aslında henüz
göstermediğim
bir
öğe daha var
burada taşıma
semantiğinden de
istersen
faydalanabilirim
ama
bir iteratör
adaptörünü
henüz göstermedim
ya da
anlatmadım
diyelim
arkadaşlar
move iteratör
ya da
burada
yani bunu
taşıma
semantiğiyle
kullanmamı
sağlayacak
öğeler de var
ama konumuz
o değil
şimdi
şimdi vektöre
kopyaladık mı
ha
alianın
dediği gibi
şimdi
buraya
burada
vektörde
sıralamamız
gerekiyor
değil mi
onun için
sort'u
kullanıyorum
sort
wegbegin
wegend
ama arkadaşlar
sıralama kriteri
eğer l'si kullanırsa
ama aynı şekilde
zaten sıralı
sıralama kriterini
değiştiriyorum
arkadaşlar
const
auto
rev
p1
const
auto
rev
p2
ama beni
ilgilendiren ne
return
h1'in
arkadaşlar
second'ı
büyük
p2'nin
second'ı
uzun uzun
eğerin
string int
açılımı
yazmamak için
generalize
lambda
expression
kullandım
sort ettim
ve şimdi
dosyaya
yazdırayım
hatta
burada da
aynı
çıkışı
kullanabilirim
emirhan
diyor ki
en başta
vektörde
tutuyor
olsaydık
ama vektörde
tutamazsınız ki
burada
sayma işlemini
yapan
map
yani vektörde
tutuyor
olsaydım
o zaman
böyle bir
vektörde
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
yok
o şekilde
yapma imkanım
yok
evet
ama burada
cmp değil
arkadaşlar
veki dolaşıyor
evet
bakın
alt nokta
txt'ye
gerçekten de
istedimimizi yaptık
61 tane
uzak ara
emre canımız
başta
47 tane
yavuz
45 tane
yunuz
pensel
bu şekilde
gidiyor
peki
şimdi
devam
evet
birkaç
dakikamız
daha var
arkadaşlar
map'te
et isimli
fonksiyon da var
ilginç bir şekilde
zaten
isme
et olan
bir fonksiyon
gördüğünüzde
işin içine
hemen
exception handling
gireceğini
tahmin edebilirsiniz
bir önceki
koda geri dönelim
köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
ya da
kendimiz
arkadaşlar
yine
map oluşturalım
oraya
o kadar
gidemedik
map'in
bu sefer
bait'i de
hiç kullanmadık
kullanalım
bakın
map'in
bait virgül
link açılımı
by map
for
10 tane
yeter
10 kez
dönen for
döngüsü
my map'in
employees'i
date için
date'in
random
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
efendim string
içinde
random name
dolaşalım ve yazdıralım
map'imizi
or
const
auto
ref
date
name
minor
siyahat
date
name
değil mi?
mesela
date
dt
my map
eşittir
gürbüz
eğer burada
köceli parantez
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
bunun ne yaptığını
biliyoruz
eğer bu date
key olarak
varsa
onun
values'unu
görümüz yapacak
yoksa
ekleyecek
ama bunun yerine
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
my map
add fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
add fonksiyonunda
yine key'i veriyorum
yine bu beni
values'una
eriştiriyor
values'unu
örneğin yine
gürbüz yapıyorum
aradaki
fark ne?
tahmin edin
eğer köşeli parantez
operatör fonksiyonu
bu anahtar
olmasaydı
ekleme
yapacaktı
ama
add fonksiyonu
ekleme
yapmıyor
bu anahtar
yoksa
exception
throw
ediyor
yani şimdi
muhtemelen
tabi bu tarih
olmayacak
raskeri aldığımıza göre
exception
throw edecek
throw edilen
exception'i
yakalamaya çalışalım
yakalayalım
arkadaşlar
yine burada
out of range
throw edecek
izleyin
bakın
exception
code
invalid
map
key
type
yani sonuçta
buradaki ifade
bir
exception
throw etti
çarşamba
günü
önce map
sınıfını
bitireceğiz
map ve
multi map'e
ondan sonra
unordered
associative
containers
grubuna
geçeceğiz
yani diğer
programlama dillerinin
kütüphanelerinde
tipik olarak
hash set
hash map diye
geçen
bizdeki karşılığıyla
unordered
set ve unordered
map
container'lerini
göreceğiz
derse katıldığınız
için teşekkür
ediyorum
arkadaşlar
ve
soruyu anlayamadım
emirhan ama
function
callbackler
olacak mı
tabi
yani eğer
kursu
kursa dahil mi
diyorsanız
zaten
temel
C kursunda
onları gördük
ama burada da
onunla ilgili
öğeler
stut function
functional
başlık
dosyasındaki
stutu function
sınıfını
göreceğiz
olam ders bitmişken
kurs kapsamında
ileride atomik
konusuna değinecek
misiniz
evet
şimdi kursun
içeriği içinde
arkadaşlar
bu
C++'ın
concurrency
araçları da var
yani
threadler
threadlerin
kullanımı
tabi threadler
dediğimiz zaman
ona ne de giriyor
senkronizasyon
mekanizmaları
atomikler
vesaire
hepsi
konumuz içinde
kan
peki
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol
x